public safety committee
and we're going to start i'm going to
ask representative um
to lead us in the preservation
this time i'm going to open the public
hearing on sb
303 fn
the committee calls grant bossie for
senator hennessey
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is grant bosse i am
not senator aaron hennessey she regrets
that she's unable to be here today and
thank you for the courtesy of letting me
introduce the bill in her place she has
submitted a letter which we've provided
to the clerk
and i'll read that into the record for
you uh dear chairman abbas or chairman
roy and honorable members of the
committee the new hampshire sheriff's
association asked me to bring forward
senate bill 303 relative to
reimbursement of sheriff's offices
for prisoner custody and control the
sheriff's departments are reimbursed by
the courts for providing prisoner
custody and control services these
services include transporting prisoners
and staying with them at their hearings
in the courthouse the sheriffs are
currently reimbursed about half of what
the current per diem rate is for bailiff
service in the courthouse this bill
would bring parity between the two rates
and fix an oversight in the budget
although the bill has a fiscal note
there is no additional appropriation for
the rate increase with the increase in
virtual court services the instances of
custody and control are going down
the budget amount appropriated to the
judicial branch for court security
including custody and control can absorb
the rate increase if virtual appearances
continue at current rates
representatives from the sheriff's
departments are here to testify in favor
of the bill and we'll be able to answer
any questions you may have thank you for
your consideration my apologies for not
being able to be with you today please
reach out if you have any additional
questions sincerely senator aaron
hennessey district 1.
with that i will close my testimony and
defer any questions to the senator and
to the sheriff's behind me
thank you for your testimony and
introducing the bill thank you
the committee now calls christopher
connolly
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak uh
before you on um
uh senate bill 303
um for those of you that are not
familiar uh the sheriff's office
provides custody and control uh within
our courthouses in the state so
essentially what that means is uh we
move inmates
from the various correctional facilities
to their court appearances at the
different courts we have court offices
that provide
custody and control
for those folks once they arrive at the
courthouses so that means that they work
in the cell blocks they remove the
inmates
from the
cell holding areas transport them back
and forth within the courthouse to the
various courtrooms in the building so
this is a inherently uh difficult and
dangerous job
so certainly we feel that they should be
reimbursed at the same rate
as other court security officer
functions
is currently at about half of
that as mr bosse indicated
when he introduced the
the bill on senator hennessey's behalf
so
really what we're doing is seeking
parity for those inherently difficult
jobs and dangerous jobs that these folks
perform
we have a great difficulty
in
recruiting and retaining folks for these
positions
you know when folks can look at for
instance the posting possibly from
dunkin donuts or one of the fast food
chains uh and look at that type of work
as compared to moving some potentially
violent and dangerous individuals around
a court uh house it certainly does not
always make an attractive proposition to
work a custody control function
so it's really important that we
try to achieve parity with the pay that
our folks that are moving these
dangerous folks within our courtrooms
are are performing those duties and
they're also uh obviously during the
performance of those duties ensuring the
safety uh of those attending for a court
appearance uh the judge attorneys uh
witnesses jurors and things like that so
it's an extremely important
function that they perform
happy to answer any questions
representative panalockas
thank you mr chairman um could you tell
me sir what was done before
uh this is the first i've ever heard of
the reimbursement
there we go okay uh so the state
actually has been reimbursing uh the
counties um
for custody and control but it's been at
a different rate so the rate of
reimbursement is about half what the
state reimburses other court officer
functions for so um for many years
there's been a disparity in that pay so
this actually is not a new concept
in the state reimbursing for the
services provided by the court officers
but what it is is um
attempt to achieve parity in what they
are being paid
thank you you're welcome
a question from the chair
um
are these officers are they sheriff's
deputies are they part of the sheriff's
department
so they um work for the sheriff's
department but they are court officers
uh the vast majority are not sworn so
they're not deputy sheriffs that per
diem uh court officers that that come in
and work as needed for us in those
various roles
okay so they're not they're not salaried
employees with benefits and such as part
of the sheriff's department that is
correct they're per diem no benefits uh
received by these folks okay one last
thing i don't know if you said when you
started if you could just say your name
and your position don't buy apologize mr
chair yes my name is christopher
connolly i'm the hillsborough county
sheriff i've been new hampshire law
enforcement officer for uh just about 35
years now
thank you very much thank you mr chair
any further uh yes representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
coming today
so currently they're only you know the
state reimburses you about half the cost
so once
if this passed
and was signed into law
then would the money come from the
county residents for each county and
they would pay for their portion you
know
of those you know the duties here
so currently uh custody and control uh
court officers uh reimbursed at 65 a day
in our perimeter and security which are
the folks that uh that you would see at
the front door for instance as you get
screened through the magnetometer are uh
reimbursed through the state at a rate
of 121
and uh change
let's see 121 i'm sorry 120 dollars and
18 cents
so would the money still come from the
state you know if this passes or will it
come from the county so the
reimbursement uh so what would this
would do is increase the reimbursement
for those custody and control positions
that we receive from the state so the
county uh bills uh that various counties
bill the state um for those
reimbursement services but the issue now
is that the perimeter
perimeter and security folks are
reimbursed at one rate and the custody
and control are reimbursed at a at a
lesser rate about half
thank you thank you
and just to be clear the the services
that these folks are providing are for
the state that is correct thank you
representative newman
thank you it sounds like
your current situation reimburses people
about half what they could make at
mcdonald's
and this might bring you up to pretty
close to parity with uh people that work
in those types of jobs is that incorrect
mathematics
yes the pay is quite low for the
responsibility and inherent danger
involved in these positions for sure so
this is just a pretty good step
thank you yes that was just my opinion
i'm sorry thank you
another question to the chair if
someone's injured performing those
duties um are they paid
for their injuries from the from the
state or from the county so they
actually would fall under uh workers
compensation
if those injuries you know were
sustained during the course of their
duties
thank you
there'd be no further questions oh one
more go ahead representative
uh thank you chair uh thank you protect
my question absolutely
so does a county ever
supplement the pay
for these people so it depends on the
county um some counties do
some don't
some pay at additional rate
if their county delegations authorize
that so that which makes it a bit more
attractive
obviously to recruit folks
and some counties make up the difference
uh currently from the 65 dollars to the
120 for that parity so it's really the
reimbursement rate that is not um
on on power
oh thank you i don't understand how you
can recruit anybody to do those
positions for such a low pay
it is a challenge and it's getting more
and more challenging thank you very much
thank you representative
uh yes representative welch
thank you uh
isn't it true that the only
court officers who are getting that high
pay now work at the supreme court
uh so i am not sure what the supreme
court court officers make
i know that the language in this bill
refers to the um the administrative
office of courts the contract that they
have with their court officers so
essentially it would bring all court
officers into this um
same pay scale and bring parity but i do
not know what the supreme court folks
make
recall
it took about three years to get you
this payment in the first place so i'm
i'm in favor of this would you believe
well i appreciate that thank you
yes representative newman yes
thank you regarding your staffing how
many people currently do you have doing
this and how many would it how many
would you ideally like to have
uh that's gonna vary depending on the
counties uh speaking for my county
hillsborough county is the largest
county we actually have two superior
courthouses that we staff along with a
number of circuit courts um
so right now i'd say that i am probably
right around
between 50 and 60 court officers
now not all of them are able to work
five days a week so we have to mix and
match so it's it's um i'm not able to
give you a concrete answer it's kind of
a moving target frankly uh and we'll
have additional folks that come in if we
have a long duration trial a jury trial
or things like that sometimes we have to
ramp up um
but uh ideally uh i mean i would love to
have an additional 20 or so to choose
from in that in that pool so we'd be
able to to ramp up and adequately staff
you're welcome thank you
representative newman
thank you
um
so
do these people on a per diem basis
perform many of the
many of the functions that the other
court officers do other than just
transport people around or so um again
speaking for hillsborough county all the
court officers that i have are
cross-trained so they're able to provide
functions both for instance in the cell
block uh and or running the magnetometer
at the front door so all those folks are
able to to fit into a position depending
on where the need is for that particular
day follow-up follow-up
whether they're per diem or not i'm just
trying to figure out if there's a
difference between people oh i'm sorry i
misunderstood they they're all per damn
they're all per diem they're all the
team that we see are pediatrics that's
correct some get a higher rate than
others it depends on the county some of
the counties are paying a higher rate
than different counties so it really
depends all the court officers that you
would see for instance if you went into
the hillsborough superior court are
being paid the same whether you're at
the north or south courthouse or any of
our circuit courts in the county
one more follow-up
even
so they are all there are they are
i thought i when i heard your previous
testimony i thought you said
are they all per diem that's correct
they're all predicting them okay thank
you you're welcome thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
if i might miss chair i do uh sheriff
richard he had hoped to be here this
morning uh but he had a incident with a
turkey hitting his cruiser i hated when
that happened so he was not able to be
but if you could submit that to the
clerk okay thank you thank you
okay yes yes
and the committee now calls mark brave
um
you're going to wave off okay thank you
sheriff bravo waves off
is there anyone else wishing to testify
who hasn't testified on this bill this
morning
there being none i'm going to go ahead
and close the public hearing thank you
very much
false
thank you
check here
i know
all right the committee will come to
order
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on senate bill
303. well relative to the reimbursement
of sheriff's offices for prisoner
custody and control
representative welch you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
yes i i would recommend an octopass with
senate bill
i'm going to
give respect to the dean and
acknowledge representative pantelock
says the second oh thank you
representative welch do you wish to
speak to speak to the motion
uh
this bill actually immense language that
we put on several years back
it was a three-year fight with a
judicial branch
to get them any money at all because up
until then it was a county
responsibility to pay
these folks
and one of the reasons that we
negotiated
we got it in all the courts except the
supreme court and i think if you look at
the uh
at the statutes you'll see that they
have
supreme court security officers
this puts them on a power
i think it's long overdue we would have
done it back then but it was a big fight
actually it actually cause the
impeachment of the chiefs to stay with
brock
and
i think
passing this will just make everything
equal
so i'm like 100 supportive of this and
would you know probably ought to pass um
my only question i have is that there is
just
i think the front uh my friend from
from portsmouth uh representative
pencillock was raised was just a
question about the the methodology on
the fiscal note on talking about the
state police colonel but
um
and i just did it a little weird
that's in there but
it might have been left behind from
another amendment
what
what's the exact question i mean it's
not well it's not a question we're we're
an exec so um but my well my but my
issue is i just i don't know how what
that has to do with with sheriff
with the sheriff pay and you know
representative welch you want to give
that a try
i'm not sure how this bill was before it
was amended to the senate but clearly it
has nothing to do with state police
right that's the question that that's
fiscal note was probably written on the
original bill yeah and then it was taken
out
i mean it's fine with me i'm going to
support it
although this isn't a hearing where
where we would receive any input from
the public i do see some
sheriffs if if we're saying anything
that's not that's if that's not
consistent with the intent of the bill
please let us know
representative burt
thank you mr chairman
if i understood correctly the answer
from the officer
you know the money is going to come from
the state
which i believe really should come from
and right now some of it's coming from
the county
i mean even though it's all the same
money i mean it's coming out of the left
pocket or the right pocket but you know
bottom line it should come from the
state
oh it does now
okay all right yeah that's where i was
confused was if if
you know if the county is paying for
some of this now
and
yeah
you know the county's losing money on
this presley yeah so clean up the
language thank you mr chairman
representative newman
yeah just a parliamentary inquiry i i'm
reading the language about the fiscal
note if the fiscal note has an error in
it or or it doesn't make sense it
doesn't really have an effect on the
bill if we pass the bill is that correct
it does not what becomes law is not the
fiscal note but becomes large is the
balance thank you and typically the
fiscal note isn't amended with
a bill amendment well if you attach it
so if you attach it to the bill then it
has an effect
but you won't you don't
not exactly what becomes law is the
actual bill the fiscal note really
offers maybe some input on the
well the financial the fiscal impact of
what what the bill would thank you if it
became law
as introduced
at this time we can now move the
question
if you weren't
if you're in support of the motion of
ought to pass please say yay if you're
opposed
please say nay the clerk and i'll call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch
absolutely representative burt
yes
representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes clerk votes
yes representative testament yes
representative folsom
yes representative pratt
yes
representative marston
yes representative harriet gathright yes
representative pantalakis yes
representative jack yes representative
boardney yes representative muse
yes representative ray newman yes
representative sue newman
yes representative man of all yes
representative bradley
yes representative espitia yes chairman
abbas
chair votes yes 21 nothing
representative
representative welch will you prepare a
majority report
chair i i just have a question
so we did an act of password
should it not been occupations amendment
because no the the senate amendment
there was no there's no house amendment
yes all right all right
thank you
21 years zero names the motion passes
um
this time we will now close the
executive session on senate bill 303
committee will be in recess until 9 45.
mr chairman can we vote like this the
rest of the day
we can try
it's a possibility
i know
all right the committee will come to
order
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on senate bill 376
that is relative to creating a border
review
police ins board of
a board of review police incidents
involving citizens affected by mental
health issues
before we begin i did receive a
notification this morning that
the prime sponsor will is running late
to a prior commitment we'll be here in
the afternoon however we're going to
open the public hearing because there
are members of the public present that
wish to testify
and if they're
a member of the public
well i have two cards
but if someone wouldn't mind just simply
introducing the bill they don't need to
do anything more than a speak on the
subject matter that they won't be
excluded from prohibitive masking
questions if someone
good morning mr chair
and criminal justice committee i'm here
to introduce senate bill 376-fn
relative to creating a board to review
police incidents involving citizens
affected by mental health issues
thank you representative
make sure i recess the
don't i'll hearing you too
and
may everyone just make sure i recess the
hearing not
close the hearing
so we're all going down together
at this time at this time the chair
recognizes holly stevens
good morning chair and members of the
committee my name is holly stevens and
i'm the director of public policy for
nami new hampshire it's a pleasure to be
here testifying in front of you this
morning
nami new hampshire
is strongly in support
of senate bill
which as you just heard would create
a study committee to look at putting
together a review board
for incidents
where there's an officer involved
shooting and it would also provide some
additional funding for cit training
based on an analysis done by the concord
monitor in new hampshire
more than 60 percent of the people shot
and killed by police
in the last decade had a mental health
issue
right now there is no federal or state
agency that collects data on the role
that mental illness plays
in these incidents
but in looking at
data that's been compiled across the
country by
certain news agencies
when you compare it to new hampshire new
hampshire has a higher
incidence
of
folks that have mental illness that are
involved in these
incidents
and i do believe higher incidents in
general per capita
having a review board to look at these
incidents
is paramount in assessing
whether different interventions could be
used to achieve a different outcome
the review board could assess the timing
of interventions
and what training is needed
to execute these
interventions to achieve positive
outcomes and so the study committee
that's created by senate bill 376 would
be able to gather information from all
the key stakeholders to recommend
what the review board should look like
in new hampshire
secondly
this bill appropriates some funds for
cit
training for
specifically for
the smaller departments
and for the more rural departments
it appropriates funds that can be used
for the overtime backfilling for the
overtime
as well as travel and
and
meal expenses
um
and we we strongly uh support this
aspect of the bill as well but we would
suggest one minor amendment and i do
have
copies of some suggested language if the
if the
committee would like to look at that
which would
just add um into the language
um
that this money could also be used for
facilitation and instruction
of additional training sessions
uh as it is right now the appropriation
is
only to be used for the back filling
and for
meals and travel but there's but it
doesn't i think
they left out um additional funds for
the the cost of the training itself so
we have some suggested language that
would just put that back in and as i
said i don't know if the committee would
like
a copy of
what we've suggested
you may you may pass up any materials
thank you
so in wrapping up i know there's some
folks that that have a lot
more personal
intimate knowledge about this bill
so i will leave it there
and just say that we
urge the committee to vote ought to pass
and consider the amendment that
we
suggested
with that i'll take any questions
representative pandolakis
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
you want this board to be set up
inside of the police standard and
training
is that correct
yes thank you for the question this
isn't something that
nami new hampshire wants the programs
the pro the cit program itself right now
that is existing
is set up through the police standards
and training they get the funding and
then they contract out to the vendors to
provide the training
just so happens that nami new hampshire
is the vendor currently that provides
that training
so
we just want the the program to
expand and continue um
we're not the entity that is behind
where that money goes i think direct
commissioner skipper director skipper
director skipper is here um that can
they answer any questions about um you
know why the funding goes through to
them okay thank you very much
representative
thank you mr chairman if i understood
you correctly you said that the
cit program was
uh in your view
primarily for rural and smaller towns
could you
both explain why that is and how that
would work within the context of the
spill yeah uh so the cit which is the
uh crisis uh intervention crisis
intervention team training
um
isn't
just for rural and small
it's for any police officer any first
responder actually there's a lot of
fire and ems that go through this as
well
the the
what we found though is that for the
smaller
departments and the departments that are
more rural
they don't have enough personnel to be
able to send somebody to a 40 hour a
week course
so in order to be able to make this
available to them as well
this funding
will help those departments backfill
and get personnel in to cover
when that officer is gone for that week
because otherwise they wouldn't be able
to participate and it would only be open
to the bigger departments and the state
police that have ample
staff to be able to uh
cover those shifts
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
thank you for your testimony here today
i have a question in regards to mental
health
why or is there is the mental health
of
people doing more to help people with
these kinds of problems because what i'm
hearing you say in this bill is that we
want the state through the police to do
something
and that's fine and dandy
but i'm also looking at
what is mental health people we have a
mental health in manchester and
are they
doing things and families have to go to
them first because i would think they
don't go to the police looking for help
because i think that's the issue is
we have them on the streets all over
and it becomes a problem and then all of
a sudden an issue comes up with the
police are involved and they don't know
how to handle it but
how do we handle the mental health issue
prior to the police getting involved
and thank you for the question um
the state uh just recently on january 1
of this year
we had enacted statewide
mobile crisis response within the state
and there's a centralized number that
anybody can call for a mental health
crisis
so that is also another system that's
working in parallel with this so that
um there is another option other than
just calling
and having the police show up
that being said there are still going to
be
those
times when the police are called or are
are needed
and when those times happen
it's best to have an officer who's been
through this training
that can help de-escalate the situation
while working with the individual
representative marston you recognize for
a follow-up
can you tell us where we would find like
a number to reach these people that do
this kind of intervention
the mobile public side by the state
there is a i don't have the 800 number
with me right now but i can certainly
get it to you and as of
i think it's july 15th or 16th um
there's going to be a
nationwide
mental health crisis number that's going
to go into effect that's 988 but that's
not going into effect until july
until then we've got the the 1 800
number
that will still remain live even after
the 988 so i can get that for you
representative thank you
see no hands raised i want to thank the
witness for for her testimony thank you
the committee calls ken norton
thank you chairman abbas and committee
members my name is ken norton and i'm a
licensed independent clinical social
worker in new hampshire
and i'm the former executive director of
nami new hampshire
and i'm here to testify in support of
senate bill 376. it's unfortunate that
senator guyder wasn't able to be here
because he has a lot of
great background to offer but i'll do my
best
by way of background for me i've trained
law enforcement officers off and on in
new hampshire for the past 35 years and
i've served as a subject matter expert
for the department of defense the
veterans administration the federal
substance abuse and mental health
services administration
and the police service of northern
ireland
i serve on the national suicide
prevention lifeline steering committee
closer to home i was on governor
sununu's law enforcement accountability
community and transparency leak
commission
and i've served on the legislative
commission's task with addressing
post-traumatic stress for law
enforcement and first responders as well
as the one for military and veterans
over the past several years i've been
involved in a number of high-level
meetings regarding officer-involved
shootings
and with the
attorney general and members of the
attorney general's office the department
of safety new hampshire state police
police standards and training department
of health and human services governor's
office and concerned legislators and
these discussions resulted in the bill
before you today and i thank senator
gaida and the other sponsors of this
bill the interest in this bill um
is several-fold and it includes
as holly stevens stated the high number
of people with mental illness who are
victims of officer-involved shootings in
new hampshire
and how training and policies could be
improved to reduce the incidence of
those shootings and then the mental
health impacts on the families of people
who are killed or injured in an
officer-involved shooting as well as the
mental health impacts on the officers
themselves and on their families
the bill is two parts as she explained
there's the crisis intervention team
training component of it and uh cit as
it's called is considered the gold
standard for law enforcement and first
responders relative to training about
mental illness and de-escalation of a
crisis
and the 2015
president's task force force on 21st
century policing
recommended that every
law enforcement officer receive the
40-hour crisis intervention team
training and there is some as holly
mentioned some current cit training
occurring in the state of new hampshire
by
nami new hampshire together with police
standards and training and also a
component of it under a federal grant
but as holly testified the biggest
barrier to
to getting people to the training
particularly for the smaller communities
is the cost of sending an officer for 40
hours and then having to backfill
either with overtime or to pay
for them to come and that's part of what
the fiscal note in this bill addresses
she mentioned the december 2021
three-part series and the concord
monitor called shots fired which
recently won a national award and i
encourage you all to read that series
there's a link in my written testimony
about the 60 of people in new hampshire
involved in
officer-involved shootings with mental
illness
and that series was three parts the
first part was sort of the
how um
how police came to be on the front lines
of crisis intervention for people in a
mental health or substance abuse crisis
and
and also as holly mentioned that is
transforming right now but it's still
certainly
a key issue and the second part was
about the impact of the family whose
loved one was killed by police this was
an incident in meredith and the third
part of the series was actually focused
on the officer the officer has never
returned to duty
has severe post-traumatic stress
disorder from that incident is disabled
and anxiety and it has had a profound
impact on him and his family
the
um
the purpose i want to be clear about the
second part of this bill that the
purpose of the committee would not be to
review the determination of the attorney
general's office about whether
a shooting was legally justified or not
the purpose would be to
examine
what happened before that which might
have averted the use of deadly force and
what lessons learned might be
incorporated into policy and procedure
as well as improved training and i would
note that
that the current reports by the attorney
general's office contain this
boilerplate language in every report
and it says the attorney general does
not investigate or opine on the
particular procedures or tactics used by
law enforcement officers instead the
attorney general's review of
officer-involved use of deadly force
incidents consists of a criminal
investigation which is limited to
determining whether officers comply with
the applicable law
and as a specific example i mean i think
that the public wants to see some more
accountability relative to
officer-involved shootings as do members
of law enforcement um and the specific
specific example which kind of
was the catalyst for this coming forward
was the shooting in claremont which
occurred
and the report from the attorney
general's office which came out in
august of 2021
and a 144-page report
and
i think one of the key questions and
there are many and i have some more of
them in my written testimony but one of
the key questions and this was the
question that senator gaida called me
the next morning and uh and said
why did the clermont police fail to take
this individual into protective custody
or seek to do a compulsory mental status
exam when they had contact with him
three and a half hours before the
incident which then resulted in the swat
team
being called they observed him to be
hearing voices to be paranoid and he
admitted to
having thoughts of suicide
and um and there are a number of other
things that then transpired relative to
the swat team being involved i mean i
another question i would ask is whether
um
poking in the door of an individual
who's known to be armed and um
and paranoid um with an armored the pole
of an armored vehicle um is the best
strategy for resulting in uh a peaceful
resolution of this type of incident but
um more more questions about that in my
written testimony so the purpose of this
committee would not be
for
shaming and blaming but it would be to
look at how we can reduce these
incidents and unless we look more
carefully at these incidents
we're going to continue with the same
outcomes we've had and i would just note
that new hampshire has
established similar confidential
committees
statutory legislative committees for
infant and child mortality
for suicide for incapacitated um and and
older adults so all of these committees
exist
and they do investigations in confidence
and they report out
to particular sources what findings they
have that might
reduce the incidence of these types of
things so these fatality review
committees already exist in in the state
through the attorney general's office um
and i you know also want to clarify i
know that there have been some concerns
expressed about this bill but want to
say very clearly that um of those folks
in attendance when the the bill was
crafted which included the commissioner
of safety commissioner health and human
services the attorney general senator
guida senator rosenwald a colonel from
the state police
that that the agreement was that this is
a study committee
that we're not getting into the details
of who should be on the committee how
the committee should report out what
cases the the committee should choose
we're really
tasking the legislature with
with with studying this and making those
recommendations
i believe that senate bill 376 offers
the opportunity to significantly improve
law enforcement response to people in a
mental health crisis and reduce the use
of deadly force in our state and reduce
the negative mental health outcomes both
for officers involved and for
their families and i ask you to vote
this bill is ought to pass and i'd be
happy to answer any questions people
have
represented muse
thank you very much for taking my
question um i just have a question about
the experience of other states i know
that these incidents have taken place
not only in new hampshire but but across
the country
and one of the things i'm curious about
is whether other states have taken a
similar approach and whether you might
know
what the outcome has been of some of
those commissions that have been set up
thank you for your question um and it's
a it's a great question i do know that
maine established a public
committee legislatively and so it's not
a confidential committee but it is
um
and you can google it and and find it it
was established i think legislatively
two years ago and i believe they just
started meeting last year to look at
incidents of officer-involved shootings
and it names a number of different
law enforcement and uh and
community players on that committee
the um state of connecticut recently
they legislatively
passed uh created a position of um an
investigator general to look at
at these incidents in connecticut and
and they recently named the person that
is going to take that position it's a
retired chief justice of their supreme
court
so there there are the some of these
committees in other states some many of
them are public
but you know some of them are not
representative
recognize for a follow-up
thank you so so part of the purpose of
this committee would be to determine uh
what type of structure might be most
appropriate for new hampshire given the
fact that there is some variability in
other states correct yes thanks for your
question that's correct
thank you
representative pandolakis
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question but my question is
how do we decide
uh how does a police officer decide that
a
person has a mental problem
i mean we have a right to
have two people talking on our head
don't we and things like that
thank you for your question and um and
yes that can be a challenge um uh you
know and a challenge sometimes um in in
many different ways um
but that's a lot of what the
crisis intervention team training the
cit training teaches is how to recognize
that how to communicate effectively with
somebody that that may have a mental
illness
i think that part of the
part of what's unfortunate about these
incidents is in that 60 percent is many
of these people were known to have a
mental illness and um and as the
officers responding dispatch is telling
them or they've been to that address
multiple times or you know whatever so
so i but i think
whether a person has a mental illness or
not de-escalation techniques and things
that can um that might avert the
situation in a more peaceful manner are
good skills to have um in any crisis
situation
thank you
representative harry katherine
thank you for taking my question um i
it's sort of on the same as
my friend from the coast
um
i wanted to my question is how to see it
what does cit look like
and i think you kind of hit on it a
little bit there because
crisis interventions training but what
does it actually look like when you guys
are training the police department or
wherever this is
yes thank you for your question and it's
it's a really important question because
it is internationally recognized and
there are parameters for what it is to
look like
but i think one of the things that's
important to know that's somewhat unique
to cit is that
in new hampshire we use over 20
different faculty
that come in over the course of that 40
hours and almost an equal number of
volunteers and
those volunteers are trained and they're
people with lived experience with mental
illness
so
in the role play scenarios they may be
uh called to deal with a person who's
not locked in the bathroom and says
they're going to
end their life by cutting their wrists
and
and they go through a role play of
trying to talk to the person through the
door to get them to open the door
and what works and what doesn't work and
then they're given feedback at the end
and then a lot of times that person who
was leading the role play says by the
way i was the person locked in the
bathroom five years ago
wanting to end my life and i think it's
really powerful when or i was the mom
who called about you know my son
when
when he was threatening our family you
know and i think it's very powerful to
have that experience of communicating
with other people and realizing that we
are all you know um
potentially i'm at risk of having a
mental illness at some point in time or
feeling like our life isn't worth living
and
and it just really humanizes
the situation those 20 faculty are very
highly regarded folks in our state from
from a range of different law
enforcement mental health providers
family members and
and other mental health service
providers so coordinating this i mean a
lot of the questions are well why can't
we just do you know multiple trainings
and have you know whatever trained
trainers um because it's not the type of
training in 40 hours where you know
you're dealing with a powerpoint or one
trainer who's doing or two trainers who
are doing the training it's coordinating
these faculty and many of the faculty
volunteer and so their ability to
provide this training on an ongoing
basis and to you know to participate is
limited as well
so that's that's a good example an idea
of what crisis intervention team looks
like in new hampshire training thank you
representative bourdain
thank you chair
uh thank you for taking my question
and my understanding is it is not
against the law to be mentally ill
and if you ring this incident of
a man in claremont demonstrating
signs of schizophrenia or other mental
illnesses
what gives
how
what is the justification for a police
officer to
intervene in this instant
thanks for your question um
yeah i mean this is a very challenging
part of um of the law relative to
detaining somebody civilly for
experiencing um
instances of mental illness but the law
does provide for law enforcement to take
a person into protective custody if they
believe that they're a danger to
themselves or others
and or to
fill out or any which anybody can do to
fill out a compulsory mental status exam
form to have the person brought into the
emergency room to be evaluated
which would be likewise what you know
the police would be bringing taking that
person into protective custody to bring
them in to have a mental health
evaluation done by a mental health
professional to see whether
there was imminent danger and see
whether they met the criteria for an
involuntary emergency admission
so
but can that intervention actually uh
cause more distress for the individual
than uh what they're now experiencing
um thank you for the question it's a
great question um depending on who you
asked that question of the answer would
be yes or no
yes certainly an involuntary
admission and and you know part of this
is that
typically that
being taken into custody involves
handcuffs we've had a previous bill
which we've you know passed in new
hampshire relative to the transport if
the person is determined to go to meet
the criteria that the transport might
not involve handcuffs but being taken to
the emergency room or taken into
protective custody involves handcuffs
and being put into a police cruiser
which can be very traumatizing to that
individual
it can also be life-saving and um and i
think it's really hard sometimes to sort
out what you know what that's going to
be but i think a lot of it also really
depends on
uh the response of the first responders
what their communication level is with
the person how they walk the person
through you know those next steps and
and what the potential outcome
will be
thank you
representative newman
i noticed in your testimony you you um
referenced a uh mandatory training that
was not accomplished in in a particular
incident
um is that the cit training and would
you be looking into the factors of why
that wasn't uh accomplished and
statewide whether there is a problem
something like that or
you also mentioned um
you know armored vehicles and and those
kind of tactics how you should do that
so my question is
so you look at these instances because
you look at these cases and then you you
write a report
and the report goes back to someone
and then they either correct state laws
if they're existent and then
or write new laws to to meet that
whatever you find out and things ought
to be fixed
based on your studies that is that how
it goes how does it go from a report to
actually
having effect on correcting the the
problems that you that you find
yeah thank you for your question um
i i think that there are several parts
of it so the first part was that that
that recommendation that cit be
mandatory um
was from the president's
21st century policing report that was a
national report
i will say that
when the leak commission the governor's
commission law enforcement
accountability community transparency
commission discussed that
it was a consensus of that committee
that it not be
mandatory as part of
the initial training at police standards
and training i'll let director skippa
maybe reference some of the complexities
of that but i think that
and i should say back up a step and say
nami new hampshire does provide 16 hours
a block of 16 hours of training at
police standards and training for every
recruit that comes through
much of that is some of the basics of
what crisis intervention team training
was i think in conversations we've had
informally
if if that were to be mandatory it might
be a lot better doing it a year out when
they're you know when they're not sort
of in that um fire hose of training that
that comes through the academy so
um
but you know i will also say that some
departments have chosen to make cit
training mandatory in new hampshire they
tend to be the larger departments that
have more resources available to them
the second part of your question
i think is a little more complicated and
and
i will try to answer but i will preface
it by saying that that's really what the
study committee would look at is you
know making recommendations for how
how those reports would be issued who
would have access to those reports but
you know generally speaking i
i don't think it would necessarily be
legislative things that would be coming
out of it it would be recommendations
about policies and procedures and
training
and again would like would defer to
director skipa but you know i know in
conversations that we have had um that
i've had with him he's talked about the
ability to use some of these incidents
um as part of the simulations that they
do at the police academy um and
particularly after there was some types
of recommendations made about how things
might have happened differently
thank you
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question
again um
uh
this has been uh something that has been
out there i think since 2018 or 2019
according to the concord monitor article
and
the article also says 60
of uh officer
uh involved shootings do involve people
with mental health issues
something i'm curious about is
what have we seen in terms of
results so i guess we hear about the
negative
the negative cases we hear about the
shootings
what are we not hearing
in terms of how this intervention has
actually helped officers
handle these incidents uh more
successfully and with that with better
outcomes are there are there stories
there that we should know
thanks for your question and uh yes it's
a it's a it's a great question um there
are a lot of stories about i mean one
that comes to mind i think it was the
first cit training that we did in the
state
which was three and a half years ago and
within several days
a state trooper pulled somebody over for
speeding and um
and things escalated and uh and
they were about to make an arrest
i don't remember the exact particulars
but realized that what they were dealing
with was a mental health problem and
they instead brought the person to the
emergency room the person did say later
that they were intent on killing
themselves and that you know that that
intervention saved their life
you know unfortunately
as we know with the media we focus on
negative events rather than positive
events and um and as we look to try to
change the culture um relative to law
enforcement i i keep talking about you
know that we need to have ceremonies and
have awards for law enforcement officers
that do make these decisions that you
know that end up with a positive outcome
um
that might have gone the other way so
there's there are certainly many stories
of how
effective
crisis intervention team training is in
in changing
response of first responders after
they've had the training
i see no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony
and just for the members of the public
know
the sponsor of the bill
uh senate bill of 376 he had a
complicated scheduling so we are going
to recess the hearing he will
be here
sometime this afternoon
to speak on the bill as well
are there any members of the public
present
that we should testify they have not
already
so this time we will now recess the
hearing on senate bill
376.
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on senate bill
401.
the committee now calls senator moss
thank you
good afternoon chairman abbess and
members of the committee
i am senator chuck morris representing
district 22 the towns of salem pelham
atkinson and plaistow i also serve as
senate president i'm here this morning
to introduce senate bill 401 on behalf
of a unanimous
senate
we have an opportunity to give the
people of new hampshire back some of
their money
because of sound fiscal management and
new hampshire's business friendly
climate state revenues are producing a
large surplus through march revenues are
over 250 million in projections
this has created the opportunity for the
legislature to deliver property tax
relief to working families across the
state helping them deal with rising
costs
the property tax relief plan included in
senate bill 401 lowers local and county
costs for schools nursing homes law
enforcement municipal road construction
bridge and wastewater projects
those lower costs can be passed along to
the taxpayer in the form of lower
property tax rates
senate bill 401 includes 36 million of
state aid bridge program increasing
funds available for design and
construction municipal bridge programs
senate bill 401 increases state road
construction grants to cities and towns
by 30 million
senate bill one also adds one million
dollars to the body warning dashboard
camera fund doubling the amount we put
in the establi the establish the fund
last year the program helps local law
enforcement equip their offices with
body worn dashboard cameras enhancing
accountability and public safety
of that first million
it looks like
we only have 114 000 left to allocate
in senate bill 401 it sends 67 million
of our project projected fiscal year
surplus back to the taxpayers
lastly at the request of the department
of transportation we added language
adding the department
to operate dash cams in its fleet of
vehicles
this does not negate restrictions on
video surveillance at the turnpike toll
plazas
when the state collects more revenue
than it expects we should return it to
the taxpayers of new hampshire we should
not use the surplus to increase the
baseline of state spending
that is unsustainable and will leave us
in a hole when the legislature starts
putting together the next budget
with prices rising on everything from
gas to groceries new hampshire families
need a break providing property tax
relief through senate bill 401
is how we can put a share of the state
surplus in their pockets
this bill received a 24-0 vote in the
new hampshire senate and i'm hoping to
receive a unanimous approval as well
from the house i thank you for
consideration and ask for your support
of senate bill 401
representative espitia
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so obviously i
think you know all of us here support
making sure we have good bridges good
roads um the part that i think that
really relates to us is the body cams
and the dashboard cameras how much
so i know we're getting a million which
you know getting any money any funding
for it is great um how much would it
cost to get like you know to make sure
we actually implement like uh the
full-on program for the body cams and
and dash cams well the department's here
to speak to that but the piece of
legislation that
made this happen in the senate had a 20
million dollar estimate it was about 3
300 offices
if you fully equip them
that was for five years
seeing no hands raised thank you senator
for your testimony thank you
have a good day
the committee calls catherine heck
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is katherine heck
i represent the new hampshire municipal
association and we are here to strongly
support senate bill 401 as amended
spending money on our bridges we have
currently a 10-year waiting list for our
red listed bridges and 6.8 million
dollars in the budget right now so 30
million dollars 36 million dollars is
going to go far to move forward some of
those other projects that are in the
queue
our highways and roads as you know are
highway block grants that this would
fund will also help municipalities
be able to continue with that road work
that we know is so important however the
only thing we're requesting is that some
language be amended so that
municipalities can in fact receive these
funds
as unanticipated money has to be
accepted under rsa 3195b
and that provision has to be adopted by
the legislative body so in 2017 when
similar legislation passed they added
this language that we've supplied to
ensure that municipalities will be able
to accept and receive these funds as our
annual meetings have just
we've just gone through our annual
meetings or we're about to have them and
these funds will become available in 22
and unfortunately towns receiving those
funds would not be able to use them
because they can't accept them until
so i can certainly take any questions
you might have for me and i thank you
for your time and we are excited for
this this legislation
representative pandolakis
thank you mr chair
does that law also cover
the towns and cities being able to use
this
money for what they choose to use it for
such as a bridge or a road
so um as
the grant the monies would have to be
accepted under the rsa through a public
hearing and they have to be used for
what they were intended for the language
we're adding to the bill
as you can if you read the written
testimony i presented would prohibit
municipalities from supplanting so just
they would have to supplement and move
projects forward do additional projects
so that it is in fact getting the
communities forward this was the same
language used in 2017
and they would have to use the funds for
the purpose for which they were intended
so the highway block grant can only be
used to maintain roads or purchase the
equipment directly associated with
maintaining roads or for matching grants
for say federal dollars the bridge aid
can only be used for bridge repair and
reconstruction and of course the body
dash cam
is a grant that you apply for so it has
a very specific purpose and can only be
used in that manner
thank you you're welcome
representative bourdain
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question the amendment you
were talking about is that rep is that
uh
1330 yes
i don't have any any amount i didn't see
any amenities like the language we were
talking about
we were represented at last yesterday
afternoon representative that wasn't
shared with us
in fairness to the witness to ask her
they asked the witness about an
amendment that she doesn't have if a
member
would like to hand it to the witness and
if the witness wishes to comment on some
amendment she will be welcome to
well i did hear some discussion that
this was being considered and we just
wanted to be sure um i certainly could
take a few moments
and ensure that it meets all the
statutory requirements but we were not
aware that the amendment had actually
gone through
um
the office's legislative statement and
just declared that that amendment has
not been approved it was just literally
handed to the committee about
five minutes ago oh and that happens all
the time that's no problem sir
so if i could just take some time to
review that we just want to make sure
there's no holes or gaps so these funds
if approved by the house can be used for
the purpose in which you all have
intended
so may i email the chair of the
committee um after the meeting so i
don't delay your hearing sir or would
you prefer that i testify again after
i've had him if uh if you wish to i will
as a courtesy we'll i'll allow you to
speak on the amendment if you wish it
and i'll call some other witnesses thank
you sir
this time the witness is excused
the committee now calls steve lavoy
good morning mr chair members of the
committee steve lavoy i'm the director
of administration for the department of
safety um the department of safety does
not take any position on this this bill
as is although we do
support the use of body cameras
throughout the state
i'm here to provide
some information about the body camera
grant program and answer any questions
associated with that
as senator morse mentioned the first
round of funding was a million dollars
that was appropriated to the body camera
and dash
camera fund
there were 29 applicants all 29
applications
are receiving funding in some way shape
or form and there is approximately a
hundred and fourteen thousand dollars
remaining within that fund so this bill
would add one million dollars
to the dashboard
and body camera fund allowing us to
go through with another grant
another grant process
there's
as we mentioned there were there were 29
applicants
over 200 municipalities in the state we
do believe that there are others that
might be interested in submitting
applications and i'm happy to address
any questions that you might have
representative espio
thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question just
similar question that i asked earlier
how much would it cost to fully you know
to to really pay for i mean i love the
idea of grants and being able to provide
some funding but how much would it
actually cost to like you know do it
throughout the entire state of new
hampshire
yeah thank you for the question so as
senator morse um
indicated there's over 3 300 law
enforcement officers in the state um
during the senate consideration for this
bill
we worked with with the senate to come
up with those estimates the 20 million
dollars is the full cost amount
there were just questions about funding
50 of that which would obviously bring
it down to around 11 million
the only concern or consideration would
be if
if the program were expanded to that
size we would have some additional
staffing requirements um
with a million dollars we feel
comfortable that there won't be any
additional uh staffing requirements to
to administer a second round of funding
representative pandolakis
thank you mr chairman
in the past we've been told that
uh these body cameras
would cost our cities and towns
a lot of money in the future for the
cloud is that covered in any way
uh yes thank you for the question the
the cost of storage of the data in the
video is covered by the grants it is a
significant cost the the equipment is is
actually
a small component if you look at the
entire program but this would fund the
entire program equipment and also data
storage
thank you very much
represent the muse
yes just have some questions about the
status of the of the program so
there were 29 applicants i would assume
that um
there were 29 grants
yes so there were 29 applicants
each application was deemed eligible
and has been funded in some way shape or
form i'm not saying each component was
fully funded there may have been a few
individual elements that didn't meet the
criteria but every applicant is
receiving some level of funding those
were approved by the commissioner of
safety this week and we're moving
forward with the grant app uh the grant
process starting next week
representative muse
so so an additional question would be um
it sounds like we're we're funding um
body cams incrementally which means body
cams are probably
getting into patrol cars and onto
officers incrementally as well
what percentage of new hampshire police
officers at the 2300 that you uh that
you that you referenced um do you think
uh currently are equipped with uh with
body cams and dash cams
um i i don't have the percentage of the
3 300
i don't have that figure
thank you
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh would these uh
cameras be used exclusively for law
enforcement vehicles only
uh thank you for the question it'd be
law enforcement vehicles or body cameras
uh both
either or or both yes
all the above okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chair
if i understood you correctly uh
the um
the larger part of the
uh grant was going to
data storage then to the equipment
itself
which
suggests to me that there's
there is or would be a running cost for
this over time could you with respect to
that 20 million dollar figure that
you've referred to what what part of
that is a running cost that would be
incurred each year
so it varies there's i i don't have a
good answer because each system is um is
unique and and different um and if i can
clarify about the difference between the
equipment and the and the data costs
each municipality
may approach this in a different way
some are looking at
a leased option
where the equipment is is leased the
space is hosted for for data
for data storage and and that's a
monthly payment structure some may
choose to purchase cameras outright uh
purchase servers and store data locally
uh so this this grant program allows the
the local law enforcement entity to
decide which model meets their needs
the best so the answer really depends
upon which direction they go in
in either way
data storage becomes the big uh ongoing
question how long do you maintain the
video how much space is required um and
and that's an ongoing cost if you
purchase the equipment you'll need to
replace that maybe every three to five
years based on
based on other other technol
technological equipment replacements
but your storage costs will continue
throughout that period
i see no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony thank you
the committee now calls david rodriguez
i believe
all right i think that's right good
morning mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
david rodrigue director of operations
for the department of transportation
thank you for hearing my testimony this
morning i also want to thank senator d
alessandro and senator morse for the
amendment to 401
um that amends rsa 236 130. so if you
look at the bill there is a a section 4
amending highway surveillance prohibited
exception for dax dash cams and and new
hampshire d.o.t fleet vehicles
rsa 236 130 prohibits video surveillance
and as written prevents the department
from installing a dashboard camera in
any of our vehicles and recording that
image this amendment will allow the
department to install the cameras to
record the video and to store the video
for three days the amendment allows
storage of particular video for longer
than three days if requested by the
department of transportation or another
legal entity
dash cam video and retention of selected
segments is important to the department
of transportation as well as new
hampshire citizens and visitors in that
it will allow us to better manage an
incident with the person in the vehicle
threatening or causing harm to our
employees a complaint by person that our
staff was inappropriate
a hit and run vehicle that sideswipes a
hexa vehicle or employee
we are assisting dot internal training
assuring we are assisting the vehicle
per protocol
we will use it for public safety
campaigns to urge drivers to slow down
and move over as required in rsa 230 265
37a
and a future goal um would be to have
the video link to our transportation
management center video wall so we can
keep an eye on our service patrol folks
who are out there
alone in dangerous circumstances
i've distributed several pictures of
damage to service patrol vehicles caused
by drivers who have refused to slow down
and move over when approaching our
vehicles believe it or not there have
been motorists that have hit our
vehicles or people and continued to
travel without stopping
one of these times occurred a year or
two ago when one of our patrol foreman
was struck by a vehicle when removing
debris from the roadway fortunately he
was able on his own to call for help
you may have seen the video recently on
channel 9 of a strike of one of our
service patrol vehicles on march 11 2022
on wmur we are thankful that our driver
and the tow truck operators working on a
broken down vehicle in front of our
driver was unharmed in addition to the
many flashing amber lights this vehicle
was also equipped and had deployed a
large message sign on the back of the
vehicle
thank you for your consideration of this
amendment and i am hopeful you will pass
the bill to allow the use of dashboard
cameras as a tool to better protect our
people and the public and i'd be happy
to take any questions
representative pratt
hello i'm over here
um on the bridge money does that have to
go through the 10-year plan or would
just be uh expedient
so the bridge money would not have to go
through the 10-year plan that would be
money that will be available to the
towns and communities as once the bill
is is passed through the regular um
bridge program state bridge aid program
okay very good thank you thank you
representative
uh thank you mr chairman thank you mr
rodriguez it's a little unusual to have
highway funding coming through this can
you educate the committee a little bit
about how many bridges could be
accelerated with this money and how many
miles of municipal road could be
could be uh repaired with this
right so
um please forgive me i'm not here fully
educated and able to to speak on the
bridge aid or the block grant aid
funding i am more here to support the
the amendment so any estimation i would
give would be purely speculation
representative marston
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
listening to your testimony i came up
with this question has there been
opposition to cameras being within your
department
there certainly were some privacy
concerns particularly as we deployed
what we call our intelligent
transportation system
which includes cameras on high mass
poles on the interstate and so forth and
also as we deployed cameras through our
toll system um for for tow enforcement
um there were some privacy concerns that
those devices could be used to surveil
individuals and there's there's
recording um prohibition prohibitions to
protect against that in which exceptions
have been made for the department when
it's necessary for the department's
operations
you're recognized representative
in regards to that
who was the opposition somebody such as
the aclu or others
thank you
in fairness to the witness
he should it's probably fair for the
witness to testify on his own behalf or
on behalf of whatever organization he's
here for not he's not here on behalf of
the aclu or
so i would
expect okay
representative bert
thank you mr chairman
um you know i guess that's what i'm
looking at is the privacy part now for
the three days that you have this video
could it be downloaded to another
server and then you scrub it but it will
be out there forever
you know on this other server
so could somebody
maliciously nefariously record the video
on another device and keep keep that no
would could you
could your department okay i'm assuming
the the right
for the three days it's somewhat secure
i mean of course hacks can get in right
so it's going to be secure for three
days but then it has to be deleted
right
in between those three days could you or
the police or some government agency
grab that and say you know what you'll
delete it eventually but we're gonna
store it over here yes we could yes we
could and that permission is is written
into the wording so if we were to
have some video
for instance that showed a hit-and-run
vehicle in which we could identify that
vehicle we would definitely turn that
over to to police
if we had other video that would be
valuable for our training of other
employees for how to park on the
shoulder and and so forth we would save
that as well being very careful because
we are we do understand the privacy
concerns being very careful not to
um
provide any information that that would
um violate that but in in it i can
assure you in no way
would this video be of such a quality
and such a use to keep track of where
people are traveling on uh on our
highway
thank you
representative espitia
thank you for thank you for sharing
thank you for taking my question do you
also like you have other incidents with
let's say snowplows or things like that
where it comes to you know
where we have accidents and how handy
would it be with you know to have these
dash cams
we do have those those instances and
it's quite common for many states around
the country that do not have the same
unique privacy concerns as new hampshire
has at some times to use dash cams in
those videos they then put those to a
public website where the public can
actually log in see where the snow plow
is and see what they see as
as they're treating
the roadway people find that quite
helpful for for road condition
information and and so forth and i
assure you that they are not violating
privacy when they're when they're doing
that this video is not of that
quality right seeing no hands raised i
want to thank the witness for his
testimony
thank you
are there any members of the public who
wish to testify that have haven't
testified already or if you have
testified already and wish to speak to
an amendment that's been floating around
thank you mr chairman and member of the
committee for offering me the
flexibility and the opportunity to
review the amendment um that was
presented to you all so
the amendment as presented is very
similar to the language that we are
presenting i did want to point out a
very minor technicality on line 9 and 18
it uses the word town rather than
political subdivision and town is not a
legally defined term in the rsa so we
just would like to be very clear
and
section three
of the body cam is not addressed
in this amendment and we would just ask
that the language that we provided were
similar
be added so that towns who wish and
municipalities political subdivisions
who wish to apply for these funds again
prior to um if they're
available in 2022 they have the
opportunity to apply for these funds if
they have not adopted the provisions of
3195b
and we did put in there that this
provision would expire in fiscal year at
the end of fiscal year 2023 so on june
30th of 2023 giving towns the
opportunity to then plan differently if
they wish to apply for these funds so we
ask for that one year opportunity that
if communities would like this
to apply for this fifty thousand dollar
grant that they may have the opportunity
to do so in the next 18 months
if it pleases the chair i could answer a
previous question or provide some
information about town
bridges and aid
that was asked earlier may speak freely
thank you so currently we have a list
created by the state of our red listed
bridges i'd be happy to email the
committee that list
we have 6.8 million dollars in this
biennium budget per year for the next
two years to help assist the communities
with these red listed bridges there is a
a small match program
what this bill does is give 425 percent
more to that program and each bridge of
course is going to cost a different
amount of money so how far along the
list they would get
is going to be determined on the size of
each project but i can certainly send
you the list of
approximate over 100 bridges that are on
this red list as of 2022 and in the
highway block grant funds in this
biennium budget we have 34 million
dollars per year allocated to towns
based on partly their population as per
against the state population and miles
of road class four and five road in
their community and that's how the funds
are apportioned and i'd be happy to also
send you the schedule so you can see
what each community gets in dollars if
you'd like to see that information
representative pratt
hello
uh i have a question uh that you were
talking about the highway block grant
and that information is available is
that available online or is that
something you'd send out it is also
available online on the dot website um
it does take a little bit of
clicking to get there that's why i'm
happy to just provide it to the
committee if it's the pleasure of the
chair
as well as the red listed bridges that's
also available online these are public
documents
i think that'd be very helpful thank you
representative rory
thank you
up here sorry that's okay
if you're aware
does the state provide a grant program
to municipalities for body armor
i am not as well versus i should be in
all um public safety and criminal
justice grants i there have been at
different times and do you mean bullet
proof that yes that's what i mean um i
do my no my own police department at
different times has received grant
funding for those types of things but i
think there's people in the audience
that might be better versed to speak to
how that works than myself thank you
representative bert
thank you mr chairman
when you send the
list of the red listed bridges
is there any way you could
separate
you know i'm trying to think how to word
it
what is really ready to fall into the
river and then also what is
just out of compliance with today's
standards because i remember the town i
grew up in in vermont they had these two
bridges for red listed
a flood came through
moved him a couple inches but when the
guys showed up to take them down
they said these bridges would have
lasted another hundred years because
they didn't come down
so i was just wondering but they were on
the red list so is there any way to but
they weren't in compliance with today's
standards is there a way to do that so
um
i'm with the municipal association and
the dot and their engineers do a great
job of going around and determining
priority need and bridges are get
allocated funds based on priority need
and the list i'll send you will indicate
that but that is out of our scope to be
able to determine
who would get funding first that that's
a state
in the state jurisdiction
okay thank you thank you sir
representative uh thank you mr chairman
uh would you agree with me that that a
redless bridge
can no longer simply be functionally
obsolete as the representative from
goffstown referred to but it has to be
it has to be structurally deficient as
well in at least one axis
that is my my personal understanding of
how the process works sir but i am not
an expert in this area
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for our testimony well thank
you chairman and thank you to the
representative for providing her copy of
the amendment i appreciate your time
today
are there any members of the public who
wish to testify that have not testified
already
seeing no hands raised at this time we
will now close the public hearing on
senate bill 401
we'll
uh
yeah if
the next public hearing schedule for 11
i uh
if i can just address the committee i
i know last i didn't do this the last
time we were scheduled to be here
but prior to that hearing that
we had the passing of
the former chair of this committee
and uh
if anyone wanted to take any time of
personal privilege to make any comments
it's a public hearing and the floor will
be yours you'll be recognized
i can start if it makes it makes it
easier i know last term was my first
term and i served with
representative cushing
and he was the chairman of this
committee and believe it or not he
taught me a lot
i didn't use everything that he taught
me to make his life easier but when i
asked him why he would do such a thing
he said it was about public service
so
i carry that with me and you know
i sometimes try to explain procedures to
some other reps then use that to make
my job more difficult
but again it's about public service so
that's what i learned from
serving with representative cushing and
that was meant a lot to me
so
if anyone else wish to make any comments
they'll be so
recognized he also gave me some good
advice
when i was appointed as chair the one
thing he said was don't mess with the
dean
that's the only advice he gave me and
i've
that's why i never mess with you laura
and that one vote mattered
anyone any other members wish to
represent muse
i had um
interesting experience with
representative
cushing having covered him
as a reporter
during his uh his seabrook days
and
looking at new hampshire from afar over
the years
i was out of state i had a 25-year gap
between
the jobs i had in new hampshire the
first time and
and when i came back
and one of the things that uh that
surprised me was how
after so much time um
he was still at it um you know not only
trying to fight the good fight around um
around energy
around things like nuclear power but had
expanded it
into areas like the death penalty and i
know
not all of us were always on the same
page i think
even some of us democrats sometimes
were not necessarily always on the same
page with everything that he advocated
for
but we had
great admiration
for his passion and one of the things
that he also did that i admired as a new
legislator was
he
he made it a point to become skilled
when it came to
things like parliamentary motions and
understanding how the process worked
you know he clearly loved the new
hampshire house uh his work with the
anniversary committee
um
you know was really amazing and
uh
just a it it's an interesting thing to
leave a place in your late 20s uh and
come back and you're in your late 50s
and to find some of the same people
still in place uh and still making a
difference um
and he was somebody who through his
entire life
um
made a difference for the state and made
a difference for the people around him
and uh
i know i miss him every day um
and uh and i agree for his family um
and for the state um
he was an amazing individual and we're
not gonna see too many more
like him
uh come this way again
well like i said i'm before the house
i've known money since the seabrook days
and i we're on different sides of the
fence then
one of the things i always admired about
him is
is trying to do things for the public
good
most of the time
i think most of us have that same goal
we're all here for the same reasons
sometimes those goals
differ
i always respected them
and uh
i liked them
even though i didn't agree with them all
that often
it's a good man thank you
well
if
at this time we'll we're going to be in
recess to 11 15 but if at any point a
day any other members wish to
take a moment of any personal privilege
on that topic they would be so
recognized
yes
committee will be in recess to 11 15.
under which one
yes
yeah no the bridges i understand
it was an artist
very excited
shut up
the committee will come to order
this time
we will now open the public hearing on
senate bill 456
establishing a law enforcement conduct
review committee in the police standards
and training council and making an
appropriation
there therefore excuse me
the committee calls grant bossie on
behalf of senator carson
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for welcoming me back a
utility player has to play a lot of
positions and uh
today i am subbing in for senator carson
uh here to introduce sb 456 on her
behalf she is the prime sponsor this
bill establishes the law enforcement
conduct review committee within the new
hampshire police standards and training
council it appropriates
350 000 in fy 23 to fund it this stems
from a recommendation in the final
report of the new hampshire commission
on law enforcement accountability
community and transparency known as lee
act
to find a way to review and receive
complaints of alleged misconduct against
law enforcement officers this bill is
the result of that work
the house has already passed parallel
legislation and this bill helps
consolidate the goals of the house and
the senate along with the various
stakeholders who helped craft this
consensus solution
sb456 received the unanimous support of
the senate judiciary and finance
committees and cleared the senate twice
on a voice vote senator carson asks for
your support of this pragmatic
bipartisan approach to how new hampshire
handles complaints of police misconduct
if you have any questions for senator
carson i will make sure she gets you an
answer but i would defer to the
stakeholders behind me today thank you
again for allowing me to bring this in
on behalf of senator carson
thank you for your testimony thank you
bill
the committee now calls matt broadhead
thank you chairman members committee i
learned about this testimony i mean this
hearing about 15 minutes ago so i'm
sorry if i'm not as prepared as i would
like to be but i have testified on
similar bills uh before you on a similar
bill before you hb1682
this bill is functionally
verbatim there is one change that had
flagged for the committee
there was an amendment in the senate
version
which is on page
of the bill lines
34 35 and 36 were added
i believe it was at after the inquiry of
senator khan
who
thought it would be a good idea to
define administrative suspension
and so there's a definition in there
that was added
other than that it's uh basically
verbatim um there wasn't an uh the house
bill um
the
when when it went to finance committee
they slashed the appropriation in half
the idea being is that the effective
date was uh january 1st for this
legislation and that they would only
need six months of funding uh for the
end of the biennium so um they they that
that was their prerogative on that um i
believe that's the version that had
ended up passing the full house
so other than that there are
this bill is verbatim to which to hb
1682 which this
committee
passed unanimously which the house had
passed unanimously
so it therefore it serves the same
purpose which is
to provide
oversight and accountability and
investigations into police misconduct
increased transparency for confirmed
violations of police misconduct it
promotes consistency and uniformity
among police departments as to what
constitutes reportable misconduct and it
balances all of these important
interests with maintaining the privacy
interests of individual police officers
who are the subject of frivolous
complaints
but it also allows local police chiefs
to maintain local control over their
employee discipline matters
feedback that we've heard
on all of these issues from diverse
community stakeholders this was uh the
brainchild of the governor's lee act
commission um
and it um
it brought together people from all of
over the the community
and both law enforcement and non non-law
enforcement and this was a unanimous
recommendation from that committee as
well to to stand this thing up there's
about two years of work that went into
this
piece of legislation with a with a
diverse group of of people
and it it strikes a much needed balance
and makes
great progress in an area that new
hampshire has already been a leader on
which is
increasing
accountability
in policing but doing it in new
hampshire's way
so
that's about all i have uh for today i
can i'd be happy to take miss uh
questions from the committee
there'd be no questions thank you thank
you
the committee now calls john skipper
from police stands and training
say it right
thank you mr chairman
thank you ladies and gentlemen
my name is john skip i am the director
of new hampshire police standards and
training
i am privileged to be able to say that i
was both part of the leak commission and
then the
committee that was appointed by the
the governor to
further work on
developing
this very bill that is in front of all
of you today
i speak in its support and uh i would
echo all of the comments
that
uh attorney broadhead brought to your
attention
and i certainly stand ready for any
questions or concerns that you might
have that i could answer
a question to the chairs is there any
advantage that you see to this
particular bill over the house version
it is uh my understanding that uh the
two
bills as amended uh
are uh duplicative they they uh are
exactly the same
except for the i think the funding which
was the only difference
thank you
representative panelakis
thank you mr chairman uh director could
you uh
kind of
walk me through how this works
uh does this take it away from the
chiefs level or
how it works
thank you for that question and that uh
uh
you make a terrific observation we
really wanted to balance
uh
the interests of making sure that the
local police chief
had um
we did not take away any authority from
that local police chief
to handle
his or her employees
and really this
as this bill is designed it's really a
belt and suspender kind of
situation where the the investigation
would occur at a local level
and then that investigation
just to to um
provide objective review would then come
to the uh misconduct committee that they
could look at it uh in a very objective
way and make sure that it was done
appropriately uh that the uh allegation
was addressed
and uh that the facts were found or
sought out and that the uh facts
resulted in the ultimate
finding of that investigation whether
it's sustained or not sustained
but we wanted to make sure that we we
did not in any way
impede on that local
chief law enforcement officer
thank you very much you're welcome man
another question of the chair if you
don't mind
what um is there a mandatory reporting
requirement by by chiefs for um once
they make a disciplinary action against
an officer to you
uh within this bill sir yes yes uh the
the bill would require that um in the
first instance
uh we'll have some outward facing ways
to collect allegations and complaints
and then we would in document that that
it came in we would then refer that to
the chief law enforcement officer
uh with with the understanding that the
chief law enforcement officer will then
conduct that internal investigation and
then the results of that would come back
to the the conduct review committee
they would review that uh there's going
to be an attorney that was going to
run that that review
uh if if the committee felt that it was
not done appropriately or there was more
facts that needed to be sought out
we would have investigators that would
come and help that local police chief do
that
likewise
this bill also provides a mandatory
report so if if somebody goes directly
to the chief and says hey one of your
officers uh acted inappropriately and we
feel that falls within the definition of
misconduct
uh
they would have to report that they
received that complaint and that they
are following up on an internal
investigation
and then the same process would hold
true once that ia is completed it would
come to our review committee uh it would
be vetted to make sure that it was done
appropriately that the facts
support the finding
and then
if need be
then that attorney
would
bring an action to
police standards and training council
on that officer's certification
and so it kind of it helps separate the
uh the investigative function from the
those folks that are going to be making
the ultimate decision on on the officer
certification
thank you and so
if an officer is being investigated um
and the officer chooses to resign
the the reporting requirement cannot be
waived is that correct that is correct
and in fact um
presently
uh
that's how we handle it we still require
that that police chief report to us that
the
the particular officer was a target of
an ia and that they resigned
during an investigation or in lieu of
termination
so we
tried to be as very transparent as
possible collecting that information
and
we have
in furtherance of that we are
we're trying to work through our
administrative rules and our process to
to make those kinds of records
you know uh public uh that is uh
we would still have some work ahead of
us with regard to that but we we do um
try to to respond to any kind of 91a
request with regard to that balancing
the interest of the of the officer
representative panamakis
thank you mr chair
you cannot
excuse me for so many questions not at
all but can a citizen from the town or
city that the police officer
is in
come to you with this uh problem before
the chief
absolutely
and we would we would take that
complaint
and then uh by virtue of this bill then
we would
let that police chief know this is what
happened
and it needs to be investigated or
we may take the complaint and it may not
fit the definition of misconduct as
outlined in this bill
so as inclusive as we want to be to make
sure we're addressing misconduct
if it's a
if it's a in-house issue if it's a
personnel issue if it's a
performance issue like work um
those would not come under the purview
of of this committee
i i just think it would have been better
for portsmouth that you've been around
to do this
thank you you're welcome
representative marston
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i'm wondering about in the bill is there
guidelines for people that make false
testimonies or false accusations and is
there a follow-up were there
prosecuted or brought to justice
that that is a a
a topic that uh law enforcement has had
to deal with uh forever and during my
experiences as a law enforcement officer
and and running a police department uh
there was always
uh
that notion of making sure that you know
people are telling the truth when they
file a report and if they file a false
police report
they do extend themselves into the
liability of of being subject to
being criminally charged for that
i think it's important to
[Music]
really make sure that if if the charges
were going to be brought
uh
that it is it was
clearly falsely reported because they
were trying to cause harm
to the officer as opposed to just their
perception of what may have happened and
that's uh you know that's that's
something that we we deal with every day
um so there there
just need to be a lot of common sense
applied to this if we're going to charge
somebody for filing a false report but
but that is available absolutely
so my follow-up question there is
guidelines within this that cover that
i don't believe that there's guidelines
specific to this but this bill does not
negate the ability for us
to
uh bring forward charges of an unflaunt
unsworn false uh force falsification
or uh
a a
report that's not accurate you know we
we could bring those charges under state
law
thank you if i might clarify it
currently exists within the law for to
for to bring a charge for a false
statement so it's not required in the
bill um representative newman you had a
question
yes i do thank you
thank you does this um would this have
any
work in collaboration with the local
police commissions or is it a totally
separate thing or do you work
collaboratively thank you
that's a wonderful question and candidly
i will tell you that i i don't know that
that came up during the conversation
when we were uh fashioning this bill
uh i don't believe
uh
that we brought that topic up and i
think really our our concern was to make
sure that we were
not excluding the chief law enforcement
officer who has
the statutory authority
and responsibility to manage the
employees under his or her control
i i don't know
uh
how that interaction would occur based
on the bill as it is presented i mean
candidly we're all in this together and
we would all need to work together to
make sure that
uh
a police officer that commits misconduct
as defined as held accountable for that
and if that would include a local police
commission to be part of that discussion
then uh i'm sure
that that that would happen but it is
not addressed in the legislation has
proposed
thank you you're welcome
to be clear though if there is a
reporting requirement from a chief to a
police commission this bill would not in
any way negate that or waive that
correct that is correct mr chairman
thank you
representative burt
thank you mr chairman
and uh thank you for your testimony uh
my understanding is uh just to clarify
the false accusation law
that it's virtually never
used um so could you do you know when
the last time anybody's ever been
charged with it because it is
so vague or i guess this is what i'm
being told that it's very vague that
i may believe what i wrote
but it's really a lie
and all i have to do is go to court and
say i believe what i wrote and it's
pretty much a done deal that's it's
dismissed
i thank you for your question sir i i
cannot speak with with uh any accuracy
with regard to when the last time
anyone has ever been charged with that
i can tell you in my experience as a
police chief and as a police officer
there were times when uh
an investigation
was launched because of an allegation
made
and it turned out
during the investigation that the
allegation was false and we if we could
prove that beyond a reasonable doubt and
we felt that the culpability of that
that false report was such to cause harm
uh then we felt confident to bring those
charges forward
uh there are some times when you know uh
people
they they know the truth as their own
perception of what they saw
and uh and again you know going back to
my earlier comment uh there are
sometimes that the the spirit of the law
would not apply uh in a case where maybe
a report was filed
in in a passionate way where they really
were not
lying in so much as they were speaking
from their own perspective
i would tell you that
when emotions are high
people believe that they said and did
things and when we look at video
of that same event uh oftentimes it is
different because human beings are
involved so
i don't know if that answers your
question sir but i appreciate the
question it does and thank you uh you
know i just that's why i love uh body
cameras
absolutely absolutely
uh quick question to the chair
when you move against an officer
certification what's the standard of
proof um
i
presently it's uh beyond a preponderance
of the evidence so it would be the same
level of proof needed to prove a civil
case in trial it is not uh
that higher burden of beyond a
reasonable doubt
thank you
uh there'd be no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you
is there anyone else here wishing to
testify on this bill who has not yet
testified
here being done i will now close the
public hearing on this bill
and the committee will be in recess
until give me a minute
145.
on
sb 299
afternoon mr chairman and members of the
house criminal justice committee for the
record my name is sharon carson and i
have the pleasure of representing senate
district 14 comprising the towns of
londonderry hudson and auburn and i have
for your consideration this afternoon
senate bill 222
which
addresses the elements required for
charging a felony or misdemeanor escape
this bill was amended um
when a
house a senate judiciary had it and it
amends the penalty for escape and this
was a request of the department of
corrections
a change in the statute in 2015 hindered
the state's ability to consistently or
successfully prosecute individuals that
escape from state facilities
this bill as amended corrects that issue
moving forward enacting clear and
appropriate lines about the penalties
that are in place when an individual
escapes whether or not force is used
and again this language was a compromise
between the department of corrections
and law enforcement to address concerns
that were raised
mr chairman at this time i will conclude
my testimony there are individuals from
the department of corrections here as
well as law enforcement to talk about
this bill and we'll probably answer your
questions better than i can so thank you
very much thank you for the record it's
uh sb 299. i thought i said sb299 you
said two two two but that's okay okay
sorry
i apologize 299 thank you
the committee now calls lynn cusack new
hampshire department of corrections
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee my name is lynn marie kuzak
and i am the
department of corrections director of
professional standards
in that
role i am also general counsel or
perform general counsel duties to the
department of corrections
coming from about 18 years at the new
hampshire department of justice
i'm here today and i thank senator
carson for
introducing this bill i'm here today to
talk to you about why the department of
corrections
is in need of a
an amendment to it i
uh my assistant or another attorney that
does legislative affairs for us
submitted yesterday to you
uh testimony i do have copies of that
testimony if i'm
i'm free to pass that out or
thank you
just start this way
i
i apologize i did not catch the um error
in the two line i still had it as the
senate judiciary and i again apologize
i should have caught that and made it
the house judiciary or excuse me the
house criminal justice
why this is important for the new
hampshire department of corrections what
we have seen since 2015 when there was
an amendment to the bill
is an issue with
any county prosecutor wanting to
prosecute an escape from one of our
facilities
in that the penalty for an escape where
there is no force or injury used or
excuse me no force used or injury
sustained so the person or others that
were escaping
is a misdemeanor
and
in a misdemeanor we have someone for
example that might walk away from one of
our halfway houses and go on a crime
spree
now they could be picked up and
certainly charged with those crimes from
the crime spree but they would only be
facing a one-year
sentence on the escape
in that it's only a misdemeanor and what
county prosecutors do sometimes is they
they just don't bring those charges or
they'll bring the charge get a
conviction but the sentence is stand
committed time
it's not an additional
sanction on top of whatever else they're
serving so it doesn't serve as a
deterrent to individuals from
leaving the halfway house or even
administrative home confinement and not
checking back in
we can't necessarily on that individual
that doesn't have a crime spree that's
committed while they're absconded from
our jurisdiction or from our our
security
we if they don't do that there's no
charge that is then associated with it
because again county prosecutors are
reluctant to bring any additional charge
when it's only a misdemeanor
where this becomes
critical to us
is when it's not just the halfway house
but when it is somebody that escapes
from potentially behind the walls
without using force and if i can bring
you back to a time
and many of you may have seen the movie
or which is a real life documentary on
the escape from denmara which is a new
york facility a clinton correctional
facility in new york state where two
individuals escaped from that facility
without using force they dug through
tunnels and this was just
back in 2014 i believe they dug through
tunnels where the heating system went
through and came out on the other side
of the facility up through a manhole
now if that was new hampshire and that's
all that happened those individuals
would only have been charged with a
misdemeanor
that's a concern that there is no
deterrent to any such action
this wasn't a problem until 2015 and in
2015 the statute changed to only make it
a misdemeanor it used to be a class b
felony if there was no force used in
the legislative history shows that an
individual who was arrested a young
woman arrested fleeing a
party where she was under
21 that had beer at the party
was charged with an escape from that
detention
and was charged with that class b felony
and people
were concerned that that type of
behavior would lead someone to a class b
having a sentence of a class b felony
we were trying to rectify that working
with law enforcement to the bill that
you see today so that it is a class b
felony for those individuals that are
previously sentenced and incarcerated
and that's all we're asking to do
happy to take any questions
thank you um
question uh from the chair it would seem
also that
if you were to pursue
somebody who was escaping
you're not allowed to cross state lines
to pursue for a misdemeanor but you are
for a felony so technically is it not
true that you'd actually have to stop at
the vermont border and watch them
continue on into the sunrise that is
correct and and it's also difficult for
a misdemeanor to get a warrant out of
new hampshire
for new england we had an individual for
example
that walked away from our halfway house
went to all the way to virginia
his and it's in the testimony his
girlfriend helped him by
renting a car for him by running a hotel
the first night by producing getting a
weapon for him
and at first we could not get that
warrant new england wide
and then east coast wide it took some
doing to finally be able to get that
warrant
because it was only a misdemeanor where
there was no force that was used
thank you
any other questions okay uh
representative burt
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
uh
you brought up dana mora
now when those two broke out with
assistance from prison staff
um
what what would the fine be over there i
know that i think both of them ended up
dead um but one did one did not one's
back did survive yes one's back in the
facility
what would the crime been there would
have been a felony or was it a
misdemeanor it was a a felony for the
escape and then obviously
um that one that died he did
shoot at state police um during the time
so there were other
crimes that were committed the one that
was brought back in was only on the run
or on the lamb
so-called on the lamp for that period of
time and had a felony escape charge when
he came back okay thank you yes
representative gasser did you have a
question nice
yes thank you thank you for taking my
question um i was just observing but i
didn't read this whole chapter here but
in line six when it talks about juvenile
correction facility
is that current and current law correct
i was just surprised to read juvenile
yes that's already in in law there's no
change to that it's just the phrase
before it
um where we inserted regat regardless of
whether force is used
so current law reads the offense is a
class b felony if the actor was on
parole and it's that last line
um because
of the
entire section
where in where it says if no physical
force was used it is a class
a misdemeanor and that's where the
county attorneys are saying without the
language that you that we've asked for
they will only ever prosecute it as a
misdemeanor when no force is used
so the language um regardless of whether
force is used
corrects that that dichotomy that would
exist
representative expedia
thank you mr chair um and thank you for
taking my question how often do do
escapes happen in our in our facilities
certainly so in the last five years we
have had 30 walk-aways now those so it's
about five to six a year
those walkaways range from anything to
gone a number of hours
to gone in one case the one case where i
mentioned the individual in virginia
three months there was a another month
where an individual walked away from one
of our halfway houses got a ride with
again
a girlfriend the girlfriend and he
made their way through atlantic city
down to tennessee and into texas and it
was
almost a month before we brought that
individual back
at a
at a good cost too to
to try to to get them back here
um question for the chi from the chair
people on an electronic monitoring
bracelet um would it constitute an
escape if they were to cut that off and
leave
yes so that's what we're saying and here
anybody that what we say is that
administrative home confinement somebody
that is has that electronic monitoring
bracelet we have had a case of that
sort where the individual
we say absconded it's an escape
cut their bracelet off it sent warnings
that it was off we went to find them
could not find him did some
investigation um he had
left and was in massachusetts with
a loved one
representative burke
thank you mr chairman you brought up a
you know a question in my head
if
to have home confinement can
you couldn't be you know charged with a
misdemeanor and be home
on an ankle brace that can you
i believe the statute in 651 i think it
is 18
allows the county facility to allow to
send people out on administrative home
confinement with an ankle bracelet yes
criminal sentencing with a felony
they have to do show
that they have been of good behavior
and we have to get court approval to
allow that administrative home
confinement to occur a little different
for the county facilities
follow-up
thank you
so somebody with a misdemeanor could be
home with an ankle bracelet and if they
cut it off they're now a felon
good question i i'm not certain of that
um
i think we we did consider
that they would be a consider they could
be charged with that class b felony for
absconding from
from administrative home confinement yes
that is correct all right thank you
representative muse
thank you um in the in in the new york
case um
my understanding is that the two
offenders are being held for very
serious charges what i what i don't
understand if if we look at the 30 folks
that have uh that have affected escapes
over the last five years
um
what are the what are the charges like
and where are they escaping from are
most of them
convicted of fairly minor charges
walking away from halfway houses or
are we talking about
serious felons escaping
from prison facilities
so of those 30 that i have um told you
about in the last five years none of
them were from behind the walls of our
of our prison they were all from either
the temporary the excuse me transitional
housing unit or th you
or a
temporary work center the twc so th us
would include calumet house down in
manchester where we see
quite a few
and i'll
explain what those are and potentially
who those people could be our shae farm
which is our women's halfway house
we have no
walk aways from shea farm
i guess
i'll leave that alone
and north end house is another
thu transitional housing unit right next
to the prison in concord we've had a few
from there and then the temporary
transitional work center
which is next to the north end house
they are individuals that are not
clas or classified as c
they are c2s still they are not
classified as c1 being our lowest
classification level minimum security
and they work for example you might see
them if you drive along main street you
might see them wearing the orange vests
cleaning parking lots or walking up to
the farm or the
walking to the
shop where we sell in industries
products they work in those locations
and what happens
on one occasion
we know that somebody left the twc to
walk up there
a car met them we had some advanced
notice because of phone calls that we
were listening to and were able to stop
that person before they
absconded
in other cases we don't have that
good intelligence or advanced notice and
they may get in that car and and drive
away with someone
those individuals could
be
um charged with
murder and are now
you know
they were serving a 30-year sentence say
they're now two years outside they've
served 28 years
to have two years left and they could
walk away they could be someone that is
a sexual predator um
they could be somebody just with
substance abuse issues and and um
we're charged with um
controlled drug possession
so it's the gambit of individuals
thank you
representative welch
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
a number of years ago
there was two people who escaped from
the prison
and i think one of them ended up dead
and the fellow who
helped him out he committed suicide
but we did an investigation of that we
found out that the guards and the towers
had no ammunition in their firearms
do you know if that has been corrected
unfortunately i cannot i don't know the
status of the weapons that they when
they're in the towers
i i don't even want to make an
assumption to you i would believe that
they have ammunition
but i cannot sit here and tell you
with 100 certainty that's the case
follow-up
during that investigation we also found
out
that they were tipped off about the
escape
that they found wire cutters between the
fences this is on the
north side of the
prison right near the where the uh
the the other activity takes place i
forget what it is now
but
they ignored all the tips i i would
i'm assuming that we have good
investigative material over there
so um under my purview as the director
of professional standards i do have 14
investigators who are very hardworking
individuals
who listen to phone calls and
many times and i would say
the majority of the time stop something
before it happens
there are instances in which the
intelligence either is not there or
new hampshire has the second largest
call volume of any facility meaning
their the ability to make phone calls
for residents through their tablets or
through
pay phones of any facility in the
country
so we cannot listen to
the 30 000 hours of phone calls that
occur
on a monthly basis
thank you
representative boarding
mr chairman i think you've taken my
question i'm a little
puzzled by the
by
the language in this bill
because it says on line for
the fence is a class b felony regardless
of whether force is used
and then on line
9 it says in all other cases if no
physical force was used by the actor or
no persons other than the actors staying
body injury
the offenses of class b misdemeanor
i don't understand
so the regardless of whether force is
used is modifying the
those actors if they were on parole
subject to a bail order or a prisoner
the in all other cases would be that
individual for example that was detained
that young woman that i talked about
earlier who um
was at an under underage at a drinking
party
that would be in that case in all other
cases so
the qualifier or the modifier is
in cases
regardless of whether force is used if
they were
a prisoner
a parolee
somebody on administrative home can find
met
does that help
i think it's poorly written myself i i
i
is it clear to you
so um
it is yes um in the sense that we
worked with the state police we worked
with other law enforcement to make sure
that we met the needs of of them through
this notion that we're not trying to
effectuate a class b felony on anyone
other than those individuals that have
walked away or escaped from
a prison
a parolee
administrative home confinement
so
yes i guess it does make sense to me
thank you
question from the chair in all of the
cases would that would that also um
apply to arrestees that's exactly my
point yes thank you for that
clarification okay thank you
representative byrd
uh thank you mr chair um i do apologize
for three questions and one
time um
you said that there was 30 approximately
30 people is that a year or what was the
um in a five year period so five years
for example we have had two so far this
year where there was a walk away one of
them was a for about two hours
and in that situation it was somebody
that was coming home from a workplace so
it as they live in the transitional
housing units they go out to
many different types of work
situations in this case it was a
restaurant here in concord
they were supposed to report back at a
certain time from their shift at the
at the restaurant
and didn't report back
somebody then called my investigator and
said it looks like we have an escape or
somebody that's absconded and within two
hours we were able to bring them back
but we still counted that as
a walk away escape where the
investigator had to use resources to get
that person back so that's
one of the types of
30 that i mentioned so it is about five
to six a year okay uh well and what my
question was is um
you know was that but it's um also
what crimes
did those 30 if any crimes did they
commit while before that you caught up
to him and tapped him on the shoulder
and said please come with me
so in some cases they were also felons
in possession where they had a weapon
they were a felon that had secured
somehow
in the one case i told you about the
girlfriend had provided the individual
weapon so that's a crime that they
committed
they
were in virginia and i believe
they were caught trying to
the the way that we caught them in
virginia is there was the warrant and
they were trying to rob a convenience
store down in virginia
so
it's again a myriad of of types of
offenses that they could commit
i do know
a little bit different
experience not necessarily an escapee
but somebody who was on parole
that had not shown up for there's a
warrant out for that individual on
parole this doesn't necessarily affect
this what i'm telling you but um we do
know that a parolee has
murdered somebody after
not showing up for for parole down in
massachusetts so
it could be anything
thank you
go ahead represent
thank you mr chairman members thank you
for taking my question i appreciate all
of the
issues of severity that
for example the ones who just addressed
and bodily injury or force used
but correct me if i'm wrong does would
this allow
someone who was convicted of a
misdemeanor
and
for example um assigned to um
home confinement
who maybe wasn't very bright and just
without even ripping the thing off
walked down to the local
convenience store to get a
soft drink or something
i mean they they could then be charged
with the felony under this law is that
is that correct
i guess there is the possibility that a
prosecutor might
somebody
the probation or parole officer that is
monitoring that individual on
administrative home confinement would
have the discretion as to what they were
going to do for next steps
i don't believe that a prosecutor would
ever take that case
but
to to be frank that
someone may
interpret it that they could
thank you
um question of the chair is is there
um is there a definition in statute of
escape
is it there is not i i did look at that
and that's why it's
that
the statute does not have that
definition at the forefront of it nor
does the definition
section of
the statute which i think is in rsa
i'm not even going to guess i can't okay
that's fine
um could you just uh because i sense
from the committee's questioning that we
have concerns about um people um with
serving time for misdemeanors being
charged with a felony for escape could
you um
briefly just tell the committee what's
involved in in in apprehending someone
who's escaped that it would in your mind
rise to the level of a felony um
offense in other words danger to
responders expenses things of this
nature certainly so um anytime someone
that is
incarcerated and is a felon
and when they
leave
they potentially may go out and do
commit further criminal events so when
we first find that they have left
in an esc if we
see them trying to leave the facility
we are able to pursue them and make the
effectuate an arrest in pursuit during
that pursuit
you may
encounter
the
high-speed chase
that could potentially result in
an incident occurring anywhere on the
highway with
civilians that aren't involved at all
the state police would have to be
get involved
that warrant that i talked about trying
to get a warrant that
is outside of just new hampshire new
england
the east coast
that's an expense trying to in one case
we knew an individual
had absconded we set up
with local police and state police
surveillance around the house
knowing that it was a house that
sold or manufactured methamphetamine
from it
so there's
potential issues with that type of
of
trying to go into a house like that and
bring somebody out
i could
potentially keep going with the
the issues that that arise and there's
maybe some in the room that are in law
enforcement that might be better able to
explain some of the
real
concerns about the cost and
the
bodily injury that may result
from trying to effectuate getting
somebody back
and just one more question
because someone's serving time for a
misdemeanor that's not necessarily what
they were charged with is it isn't it
possible that they pled that and
accepted it and they could actually have
committed a felony
that is true
um
we were just on the phone with um the
county
superintendents of three different
counties the other day about a statute
that
a little off subject here but
rsa 30 b-15
which
allows the county and the department of
corrections to
bring back an individual that
was serving for a misdemeanor sentence
um
more than one year so they get the a
misdemeanor for one year sentence a
second misdemeanor a third misdemeanor
each giving consecutive sentences that
individual
can come back or can come to the state
prison
but it's the prosecutor and that defense
counsel that have
and i hate to use the word manipulate
but have somehow managed to
to change the structure of the sentence
in an attempt that they don't go to
prison
that they stay at the house of
corrections but it really is
in all other respects it would have been
a felony but for the way that they were
sentenced so i hope that answers your
question
mr chair
representative newman
i apologize for going over the current
wording but the current wording has an
effect when it's changed
and could you just explain
the crime is effect and escape
and i'm just wondering what
circumstances or or how you would
adjudicate that on a person that's on
parole
if they're out what what do they have to
escape from
so they're still on serving a sentence
under the
um their their minimus says
that they have it's a 10 to 20 year for
example and 15 years into that sentence
they are sent out on parole so they
still have that five years left on that
sentence
so they're still serving a
sentence in new hampshire we're still
subject to the correction department
thank you yes sir
and
to answer represent newman they would
also as conditions of the parole might
say you can't leave the state without
permission to be rural officer and if
they did that would constitute an escape
any further questions
good
i was just thinking without any
conditions how would they do it but they
are still
in the big scheme of things under the
the uh control of the corrections
department correct
um quickly while no one has their hand
raised thank you for your testimony
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee
is anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill wasn't testified
there being none
close the public hearing and we're going
to reopen the public
the public hearing on
sb 376 and invite senator guida to
give us his testimony
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record senator bob
guide to district 2 and prime sponsor of
senate bill 376
uh a bipartisan bill supported from both
chambers
and one that i believe is uh in
significant need within our state it's
no secret
uh with the mental health issues that
are going on
the last four shootings by police fatal
shootings have been people that were
known to be
to have mental health issues
and unfortunately
the vast majority only 48 communities in
the state
have officers that have any training as
well as 100 officers in the state police
and
crisis intervention
we have a great program um but we have
never funded it so i met several times
with
commissioner shibanet
commissioner quinn
director skipa
the colonel a number of other uh folks
frank harris uh lieutenant harris from
down at the uh
um
the state hospital police force down
there
and we met several times and and i
finally said hey okay
we're talking but we're not solving
anything and so i said let's develop a
program so that we get one police
officer in every jurisdiction in the
state that includes county sheriffs that
includes prisons and and uh correctional
facilities
um
trained in cit
we have mobile crisis units that are
coming online all right but still the
first person on on scene is almost
always
an officer of the law and we want to
give my belief a former fbi agent and i
know a number of my friends are local
law enforcement and state police as well
give them the tools
so that they have at least the ability
to
[Music]
effectively deal with a person that is
mentally unstable
we see that the department of i'm sorry
the attorney general the ag
does an investigation after each fatal
shooting it's very narrowly scoped it is
scoped exclusively to determine whether
or not the officer's actions were
criminal or not did they meet the
statute statutory requirements for use
of lethal force that's it
but
there's never any discussion of whether
it's justified i'm sorry whether it's
necessary
and that's where my concern is all right
we part of this bill sets up money to
train one police officer in every
jurisdiction in the state
in that cit training
the second part of the bill sets up a
study committee
and and
instead of going directly to setting up
a committee to review
shootings involving mental health
issues
we want to study it because it's it's
rife with concern and i think
justifiably from our police officers
this if you read the language in the
bill
uh very clearly articulates it mirrors
the language and the intent of the
hospital board they review incidents in
hospitals periodically and they take a
look and say we should have done this
and we didn't do that and we should
improve our training with the other
thing
this would do that very same thing it
would ensure statutorily that
any review is non-punitive non-public
and absolutely cannot be used in any
prosecution any any civil case or any of
the sort because at the end of the day
what we're looking to do is to improve
the procedures that our police officers
use so they'd review an incident in
which a person was killed or not shot
okay and non-fatal and they look at it
and say you know
our training does this but it doesn't do
that and that's the sole purpose of this
but we're setting up a study committee
to study that
not a committee to actually do that
because i think that we our officers
have a righteous concern
chief goldstein had expressed concern
with respect to
well what happens if the law changes
after we implement this
committee i said well you know what i
would suspect that a number of law
enforcement agencies attorney general
and so forth by the way turned
informella was also part of these
discussions
um
that if that comes before the
legislature i think that the legislature
would have the wisdom to say we're not
interested in in using this in a
punitive
interested in using is in a learning
tool we do this in the airlines again
i'm 31 year captain for united airlines
and we self-disci we self-disclose we
make a mistake
and you also get a you get a buy you get
one chance every five years to say and
oops if you go to two now you're in
front of the faa and it's not fun it's a
long green table never been there don't
plan on going
but
again the intent is in no way nor should
it ever be construed to be punitive but
rather let's make the resources our
officers have the best they can be in
the training
to that end i have
a language not an ols drafted amendment
but language that was developed by
director skipper because in the drafting
of this bill and numbers of iterations
that it went through
we didn't provide him with a program
administrator to run this thing all
right
when this program is complete there'll
be one police officer in every
jurisdiction in the state we anticipate
that taking about eight to nine months
believe it or not
because they can train him 30 at a time
there's a very good cooperative
agreement with the national guard over
the new facility out there
and so
this would accomplish that objective it
doesn't address going forward do we want
to do we want to train more people or
whatever that's up to the next budget
cycle but this closes the gap and in the
next eight to nine months we can have
one officer in every jurisdiction in the
state
police state police have a hundred
already trained there's 48 communities
already have most of those are more
affluent communities that can afford to
spring an officer for the weeks it's a
hour course
a pretty intense course
and so i'll with that i'll conclude my
testimony and i'll take any questions
there be no questions thank you senator
uh will you provide us with a copy of
that is that a suggested amendment it is
okay director skip and nanny both um who
obviously ken norton
uh and and his colleague successor now
um
are also in favor of this thank you
thank you
there um being no one else wishing to
testify we will uh reclose now
permanently the hearing on hp excuse me
sp376
committee you'll be in recess five
minutes
yes um but no i think this is actually
okay
i agree
yes
it goes down the line
is
wow
tissue
failed
okay
this time we're going to open the public
hearing on hb 361.
the committee calls grant bossie for
senator bill gannon
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee of a bit of a recidivism
problem today uh good afternoon
i am grand posse here to introduce
senate bill 361 on behalf of senator
gannon the prime sponsor
bail commissioners are a vital and
sometimes under appreciated part of our
criminal justice system
when someone ends up in custody late at
night or over the weekend we rely on
bail commissioners to be there to help
them secure their release without having
to wait hours or even days for a judge
the legislature has supported the
principle that no one should be denied
bail simply because they can't afford to
pay it but are not a threat to the
community
for this vital service bail
commissioners charge just forty dollars
this amount doesn't take their expenses
into consideration giving a call on a
saturday night and driving across the
county can burn up a tank of gas in
these days that's more expensive than
ever bail commissioners average 60 calls
per month and 2100 miles
senator gannon introduced sb 361 in
order to authorize bail commissioners to
collect mileage in addition to the 40
flat fee you're all familiar with the
irs mileage system this would be based
on actual miles driven
reimbursed at the irs rate
like the fee the mileage charge would be
waived if the defendant were indigent
sb 361 received unanimous support of the
senate judiciary and finance committees
and cleared the senate floor twice
without opposition senator gannon thanks
you for your consideration and ask for
your support of sb 361 if you have any
questions for senator gannon i am happy
to make sure he gets you an answer but i
would defer to some bail commissioners
who are here today to tell you directly
about their experiences in the field
thank you again for allowing me to bring
in this bill on senator gannon's behalf
thank you
the committee now calls edward menses
thank you ladies and gentlemen
eddie menses from sandown new hampshire
small town that's growing by leaps and
bounds
this is my fifth year as a bail
commissioner starting
it's a fascinating interesting job
obviously needed
obviously you know i support all the
police departments
fish and game
and state police
sheriff's department
in any other department that needs me
he's right the mr bosse said we go out
all hours of the day and night and it
does happen
sometimes the when the weather's warmer
you get a lot more calls from different
departments
and we're there to serve the
people of new hampshire
and make sure everybody is stay safe
it's always our biggest concern
i have uh submitted some papers here
from police chiefs
uh they're somewhere
i would have more signatures if i had
more time
they're all in favor of us getting
mileage it's an important factor i also
submitted another
about the 18 police stations that i
cover
three hospitals
obviously
rockingham county jail and the mileage
to and fro from my house
i don't know how all this is going to
pan out but we definitely need my
mileage
um
not just because the mile the cost of
fuel has gone way up but the maintenance
of a vehicle
is obviously a chief concern
i want to tell you i definitely enjoy
doing this job
it's very fascinating
i take it with a phenomenal
responsibility to the public
and for the police office the offices
that i serve mostly in the jail
if you have any other questions i i
don't want to go off topic or anything
like that so
you okay
representative testament
thank you
thank you very much for taking my
question uh
is if i read this correctly
this mileage is not going to be paid by
the state or the county or whoever this
is paid by the person the defendant yeah
follow up
how many defendants
pay the
40 bucks in the first place
let alone the mileage i only can speak
for myself
i'm probably in the 90 percentile
and i can
if i can
i use venmo a lot of
probably 50 percent
of shade right around there paid by
credit card
debit card
um paypal
all the new technologies
in one more follow-up
no okay no
okay no no i'll wait for another
questions all right
well
some people say well they're not going
to have the money or we're going to have
to make change we're going to have to do
this to do that
i don't mind making change if i have to
whatever it takes
i mean with mileage is i think a very
fair thing for us to get
what we put the time and effort that we
put in
and knowing the right thing to do
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
in line with the last question
are there many times that you and i my
words and i'm always criticized on this
committee i don't say the right things
been stiffed
yes
absolutely
and i sometimes i know it's not going to
be i'm not going to get it
but you still provide the service
absolutely because we have to provide
the service thank you
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony
thank you
the committee now calls vincent
biochetti
afternoon mr chairman members of the
committee my name is vinnie byaketi i'm
a bail commissioner from belknap county
and i'm speaking in opposition to sb361
requires the reimbursement for traveling
my comments today will be short
i've also submitted it electronically
for you
this appears to be just another problem
that will be kicked down the road with
as feel-good legislation
we as bail commissioners have been
before you for the past four years to
try and get payment that's already
required by law but to no avail everyone
that has testified in front of you has
agreed the bail commissioners perform a
vital function
but nobody including the legislature or
the judiciary has done anything or
followed through to make those
worthwhile steps uh actually happen
instead there's now a bill to pay
for mileage which is nothing more than a
feel-good legislation
most of the bail commissioners actually
all of the bail commissioners that i've
spoken with are against this
not so much for against mileage but
because they aren't paid the forty
dollars
there are people and you'll hear from
one
that are out twenty thirty forty
thousand dollars
for coming out getting out at two
o'clock in the morning to set bail
the mileage is a feel-good thing it's
not it's it's it's not resolving a
problem you've not re you have tried to
resolve the problem the problem still
exists the court does nothing for us
and the statute does nothing as well
um
so with that i've left you some uh
electronically
submitted legislation if you have
anything for me i'd be more than happy
to answer any of your questions
represent
thank you mr chairman thank you for
coming today house representative
you you shocked me i'll be honest
thank you because i'm glad you came
thank you um
how do you do this job if you don't get
paid
well
i actually figured it out one year that
i make about
eight dollars and 37 cents an hour or
something like that considering mileage
um
mileage my time
our we have to supply our own materials
so they'll we can download the the forms
online and then we have to print them
um fax or mail
if we do if we get um
collect fees for the court
uh cash bails we have to if we can't
bring them to the court we then have to
go to the post office or bank buy a
postal order or bank check and mail it
to the court um that comes out of that
or not so even if we don't get paid we
still have to spend money so this is
kind of like a great job that is more
volunteer and costs us money than we
actually
um make
it doesn't it absolutely
all right thank you
representative panalakis
thank you mr chair
do you have to give them bail
well
it depends um we can cash bail we can uh
send them to we can lock them up for
offenses uh domestic violence offenses
or other things like that the job of the
bail commissioners to ensure that a they
show up for court and they're not a
threat to themselves or others other
than that just because they don't have
money
does not mean that we can't bail them
so we have to allow them and then we we
might give them envelope say here pay
this you know send this bring this back
to the pd i actually write it in as a as
a an order that they have to pay me i
i come up with a date that says you know
when's when can you bring me the forty
dollars
um
and some do some don't
a lot of judges don't allow
them to the bail commissioners to charge
criminally for theft of services
other judges
have said that you can but nobody's done
it yet
but that was looked dimly before uh by
the court on on bail commissioners doing
that i've been involved in law
enforcement for 30 years so i've i've
seen a lot of
this happen in the past
could i have a follow-up maybe i should
have phrased this differently okay
do you have to let them go
say fail them
is it something that you have to do
or you do it and allow them
to owe it to you we have to we can't not
bail somebody because they don't have
the feed okay thank you yes ma'am yep
question um
from the chair
does the court ever order
your reimbursement as part of a fine or
part of anything in the sentencing no
sir i've not seen that happen they also
you you when you wrote the statute last
time you said that they're supposed to
pay
as they could have you know as as would
it allow
and or they should have indigency
hearings and to my knowledge and to the
other bail commissioners i've spoken to
none of that has happened
they used to
judges used to say you're the the bail
commissioner go get the money and bring
it back before you leave the court um
but evidently that was squashed by
um either the aoc or
their bosses
thank you yes sir
representative gathering
um
i don't know if there's a question
though
can i make a comment
does it have to be a question um
would you believe i had a conversation
with the senator
and um she said that um
the bill that we passed before the folks
never got the money and one of the
reasons was that 10 of the money um
they had to cut their budget 10 percent
and that's why you guys didn't get the
money
i've heard that
that's it
thank you
representative su newman
yes
thank you
do judges get paid for the work that
they do
i'll put it this way save your save your
follow-up question everybody from the
police officer
to the judge and everybody in between
gets paid except the bail commissioner
or will receive some sort of salary or
pay
clerks
bailiffs
representative newman how much
what would be a what would be a normal
or an average bail amount that
a bail commissioner might have to
provide for somebody
it could range personal recognizance
bail where there's no money but you have
to follow certain criteria can't go
somewhere can't call people can't drive
can't use alcohol or firearms or
anything like that
to cash i mean i've set
thousands of dollars of cash to
preventative detention where you go
directly to jail do not collect 200.
for clarification
then you or another bail commissioner
might have
i don't know what you'd call it loaned
thousands of dollars for someone to be
out on bail no no no the the we just
don't get paid
we don't we don't collect that the
statute allows us to get forty dollars
for each bale that we set
per person not
not you know
okay
so if we don't get paid there is no
recourse for us to receive that payment
back
the chair may inquire
thank you yes sir if the chair may
inquire with the question i do apologize
if this was answered or said already
as a member as a
bail commissioner
what what are you classified as an
employee independent contra what's the
classification
we are classified as a contract employee
we're a contractor we're not an employee
then the court makes sure that we we are
not however
they give us regulations they give us
rules they have a manual for us they
make the rules that we can can and can't
do
but um we're not allowed we're not
employees of the court
and if i may ask for a follow-up
question and thank you for taking my
questions of course so right on the
existing law today if
you see the round trip was 25 miles
when taxes are filed i is a bail
commissioner able to
get a tax credit for those
miles already
i believe so a matter of fact i just
gave my stuff to the accountant and i
think he said that
mileage i could count
and can you clarify what that is when
you report your miles on your tax return
what is that what is that in the form of
a tax credit how does that work
uh i am financially foolish
so i give my stuff to an accountant i
give him the mileage that i've
accumulated
throughout the whole year
and he does whatever it is that he does
on my tax form
thank you for taking my question i'm
sorry i'm not i in oh if i if you don't
know the answer there's nothing right
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question yes sir what would you say
the average commissioner does in the a
year in mileage
um do you want me to look mine up sure
please
now i i do some small pd's
so far i've done 654 miles
last year i did
1865 miles
in 2020
i did
1479 miles thank you yes sir
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question yes sir
[Music]
we've been looking at a lot of bail
commissioner bills lately
um
could you just clarify what
what it's like when you um
in in the off hours when the court is
not available
um processing or providing services to
somebody who's been arrested
on your kind of interaction with the
with the police just so we understand
better
what you all do for your forty dollars
okay sure and and uh and
could you include in there whether
you have what
how are you trained or how well
you consider whether they there should
be
uh pre-trial confinement or that they
might not show up for for uh okay for
hearings and things like that
well
if i just make that's this completely
separate bill and another this the
witness is not capable of responding to
that but
i would rule that way outside the
purview
that's we are having a work session on
senate bill 294 on wednesday
but
this has to do strictly with the miles
reimbursement so let's try to leave the
questions to that
if we open up that door we'll be here
tomorrow
morning i also follow orders well so i'm
good
i
i just thought even with the mileage if
we understand what they did it would be
helpful but thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony thank you
ladies and gentlemen i appreciate it
the committee calls paul leary
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is paul leary i live at 709 central
street in franklin new hampshire i am a
bail commissioner and have been so since
march the 9th 2016
i sit here
rather than stand here opposed to the
bill
for the same reasons that
mini bayer ketty brought up it's
basically feel good
my problem is i'm not paid by roughly 32
to 38 of the people i bail
so the other 62 to 68 depending upon the
year
are the ones that are going to have to
pick up the reason that you're doing
this feel good thing
my problem because of covert and the
lack of bail commissioners
my range is
ex
grown
to four counties
i just picked up another one they're
61.5 miles from my house
so we're looking at 122 123 miles times
the standard so basically someone's
going to have to pay me an additional 61
if i have to go there plus the forty
dollars
is that fair to the ones that are
actually paying the forty dollars the
reason i say this like i say i've been
doing this since march 9 2016.
i mowed 43 959
that i will never see
i'm also required when i go there with i
have multiple bails for the same person
i'm only a lot allowed to charge forty
dollars
the problem is a lot of times our
frequent flyers the ones that don't pay
me anyway
they'll have eight or nine electronic
bench warrants each one of them require
a set of paperwork so all of a sudden i
may be there three and a half to five
and a half hours to accomplish this
i then leave then i go home
then i have to take each one of these
put them in an envelope address it put a
stamp on it and eventually go to the
post office and drop them off if there's
any cash involved i have to stop and
make a deposit at the bank
so the thing is everyone thinks it's
just this little tiny sliver sometimes
we're giving an awful lot for that forty
dollars
into speaking about mileage basically
this year i've only done 846 but i'm a
kind of a heavy user of what we call
tele-bail or remote bailing that the
court system allowed when covet hit and
i think that's part of the reason why my
area of coverage has grown
but the numbers that are still paying
are still floating when i first started
judge gordon told me i would receive
three out of five paying
which is 60
and he told me that back in uh late 2015
early 2016 so that hasn't changed much
the only thing that this is ever going
to become fair and equitable for the
bail commissioners as you've heard we're
the only ones that of the whole process
that don't always get paid
is that basically every bail
form that i write
whether it be one two five or seven i
get paid forty dollars for each one of
those
the court pays us every two weeks
by the paperwork we turn in the end of
the year they give us a 10.99 we remain
an agent or a contracted
agent
with the state we get the 1099 that
keeps irs and everyone else happy bail
commissioners are getting paid and the
thing that really adds frosting to the
cake is that the judge can waive
my bail commissioner for you 40
because the client is indigent i've
already given it the office
32 to 38 percent
now upbeat
truth and menu type thing that's only
happened once but when it happened it
irritated me that it's like you're
giving my money away
even though the law says i'm entitled to
it
so that's another challenge and then as
they said with the bills that we've had
the last few to the extent of available
funding utilize all possible means to
pay the pay the bail commissioner's fee
and shall include written evidence of
fee payment in the offender's case file
the problem is the court for as long as
i can remember has been underfunded so
there's never any available funds
but i question
you you know to use all means possible
the judge could order it
as part of the fine structure
and the first forty dollars instead of
us being the last one in the payment fee
schedule let us be the first one
those are some things that they could do
that could help
because the thing is this morning i did
receive a check through the system
but some years i only receive eight or
nine from the court
so the thing is we're not getting that
many where they're going to the court
and paying our bail commissioners fees
and that's indicated in my numbers i
only have one copy and i'll leave mr
chairman if you want i will leave that
so that you'll have it my breakdown of
the mileage all my expenses not my
expenses but the number of bails i've
done over the time
and this is the same testimony i used
when we started back on house bill
uh excuse me senate bill 772 in 2019 and
just been updating this each time as i
come back and basically tell you the
same thing the only fair and equitable
way is that we get paid for everything
we write
the court pays us and then they get it
from the defendant
and the thing is eventually hopefully it
would be a wash
thank you mr chairman
thank you for your testimony and if the
chairman inquired with the question and
thank you for taking my question it's
similar to the question i asked the
prior witness i'm just not sure if you
can answer it
as an independent contractor
if your miles are recorded
when you file your taxes is there a tax
credit received from the what exactly
tax credit but as you heard vinnie say
and one of the representatives kind of
concurred i hire an accountant
i was i spent almost 35 years in public
safety in law enforcement and this is
i'm in my seventh year doing this so
basically 41 years of doing this stuff
but i learned at an early age
the irs tax code is way above me but
what happens is i have to tell my
accountant
my car payment how much i registered my
vehicle what my insurance is and any
expenses on that vehicle
then i have to keep track of my bail
commissioner miles i also have another
business i have to keep track of those
miles and then personal miles i give
that to the account the accountant goes
through and puts okay that's a business
it's a business expense
and there's a line in there i think it's
schedule c if i remember correctly that
they list all of that stuff on and the
breakdown and the expenses are there
but still it's
it and here's the thing
i have to sit down and figure now to
keep people happy
where do i get my mileage figure from
the odometer or do i use a map program
if i use a map program what map program
but at three o'clock in the morning out
in the middle of the woods with nowhere
it's been probably at least 60 years
since i carried one of those little
change making things on my belt but it's
like when we get a bale
143 dollars and
32 cents
guys got 150 dollars
i gotta make change i don't carry
pennies nickels and dimes anymore in my
pocket i may have a few quarters we go
through the drawers in the police
department trying to find that so i mean
now we're going to complicate it even
more with the mileage so i mean this you
know when you start looking at the
totality of what you're doing it may
look good on the surface but in reality
and getting the rubber meeting the road
i don't think so
sorry i want a little outside of that
representative pantologist
thank you mr
with chairman
amount of money that use
you is owed to you now did you say there
is no way for you to collect it
to the best of my job knowledge and
belief at this juncture of time and if
it sounds like i've been dealing with
attorneys too long yes uh
i do not believe so
because i was told i can't take him for
theft services even though the form says
it the court will not entertain it
so i've given up a long time ago
and this is the state is telling you
that you have to get them bail
the way it's written if the phone rings
and i answer the phone
the last thing i want to hear out of
them is they don't have the fee
because once they do that i'm stuck i
have to go
if they don't tell me that and i make
the decision being on where the location
the time the weather and the offense
it's like nah you can write in my hand
summons i don't really need to come out
and then i can say no but if they tell
me they don't have the money i'm not
allowed to refuse
a lot of phrases me
you have to go out the state requires
you to give them this fail
and yet we do not give you
any way to collect it is that correct
at least in practice ma'am
okay thank you in writing i'm sure it
allows us somehow or other but in the
practice of we can't okay thank
you representative boardney
thank you mr chairman well thank you for
taking my question
um
when you go to uh
serve a cl defendant
do you ever have more than one defendant
at that time
uh yes the most i've had at one time was
nine at the merrimack county jail
uh so if this bill were to become a law
when actually
maori was actually rewarded someday um
would you receive mountish for
one trip or would it be for nine trips
and who would pay them outage
it would be one trip and whoever had the
misfortunes of being the first one or
the last one depending upon how the day
went
thank you very much
representative thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question you you
mentioned that your uh territory had
recently expanded did you get the
impression that that was because there
were not enough people
available to do the work
do you want me to answer that what you
want to hear do you want me to be
truthful truthful please truthful is
before covert we had over 150 bail
commissioners now we're down in the 90s
or high 80s
the reason frankly is if anyone asks us
it's like what are you crazy
to do it
the thing is we have expenses
like when you start out if you don't
have it you end up going and getting
some kind of a tablet some kind of a
printer so that you can have the ability
to go because most police departments
you go into you can't use their systems
there's no place for you to log in so
the thing is you have a lot of startup
expenses in the beginning and i mean i
just hit starting into my seventh year i
had to replace my printer that was
415 dollars
so the thing is but at least i got five
years out of the first one but the thing
is it's still all expenses that we pick
up as we go
representative sue newman
yes thank you
are you aware do other states do
anything like this ma'am to be frank i
have enough problems taking care of what
i do here in new hampshire i don't care
what someone does elsewhere with all due
respect
that's not my job follow just a
follow-up
realtors are independent contractors but
there is a national association of
realtors
do you have any kind of an association
to the best of my knowledge and belief
at this juncture of time the answer to
that is no but however each state how
they call us in the job functionality we
do are different so it would be an
interest it's not like realtors where
you're selling
you know or
moving real estate as it depends upon
the court system the state setups and
all of that yeah so each one of those
could be different representative thank
you
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question you stated earlier that it
would be better if they put your 40 or
whatever the amount be
in with the fine
and the court would collect it and then
give it to you
if that was to be the way they were
caught wanted to do it
but the thing is the caveat has to be we
get the money first not last because
currently if they owe a fine of like 700
the court gets all of that and then our
40 is the very last payment
representative roy
thank you uh thanks for taking the
question
have you noticed the change
are you getting paid less often than you
used to say
70 years ago has it been pretty much
consistent since you started is like i
said judge gordon told me expect getting
three out of five i know my clientele
base at least when i first started in
the you know around northfield franklin
tilton san beniton they're not affluent
communities in most cases so the thing
was that was the reality of it but now
like i say
it's grown
kind of but when i look at my numbers
and i'm going to leave the sheet with i
guess with the chairman
it's basically the same i float between
62 and 68 that are paying
but i'm also with a friend of mine
that's just over and a couple of towns
over he's only collecting 48 to 50 of
the time so i think it all depends upon
where you're where you're working and
what the you know the clientele base is
i have a lot of what i call frequent
flyers i have some that haven't paid me
in seven years that i've been bailing
them so we're on first name basis tell
them i don't want to see them again and
sure enough three four weeks later it's
back again so usually sometimes i bail
them four or five times a year
so
see no hands raise one thank the witness
for his testimony thank you mr chairman
the committee now calls trixie lafave
good afternoon everybody mr chair
my name is trixie lafave and i'm from
londonderry uh i've been a bail
commissioner for 13 years
um and i'm here again to speak about
senate bill 361 in opposition to the
bill
this bill as we all have been speaking
um
is intended to provide reimbursement for
mileage but doesn't give us any
enforcement for this collection
which is the same issue that we have
with the forty dollar bail
commissioner's fee we do not have any
enforcement personal enforcement to
collect this fee
the bail commissioner community we are
no further along in gaining support from
the legislative body for this particular
problem we've been here since 2019 every
single year i have given testimony over
and over again trying to get something
to benefit the bail commissioner
community just to give us to ensure that
we get that forty dollars paid
of the fork bail commissioners that
spoke at the january hearing three spoke
against this proposal and um i'm one of
those individuals but additionally
observations from some of my fellow bail
commissioners are and these are quotes
from their emails to me
if we're not being paid for our services
now i don't think they're going to pay
us for mileage either
that's nice but the bc fee would be
better
if we can't get the fee from the
defendant we certainly won't get mileage
too
something else the bc won't be able to
collect those are commentaries from
other bail commissioners
the senate moved ahead and they voted in
favor of this bill despite the testimony
to the contrary
and then in january as i had stated i
don't want to appear unappreciative of
the fact that someone is trying to look
out for our mileage but i would like for
the legislative body the state of new
hampshire to cure the the real problem
which is
allowing us to be paid for our services
that we provide 24 hours a day seven
days a week regardless of weather
um
we are the currently the email list that
i have which i've had to culminate on my
own because the state of new hampshire
doesn't afford the bail commissioner's
contact information for our fellow bail
commissioners
but what i have gained from some of my
contacts is that there's about a 60 to
65 percent
of collection from this community
we continue to answer the calls despite
the fact that it's 60 to 65 percent and
as was just reported the fall off of the
population to have lost so many bail
commissioners it's really hard to sell
this particular
gig when you're telling someone you're
going to probably collect about 60 to 65
percent of the time even though the
statute says 100 you know 40 dollars for
every single trip
but during the 2021 session there was
hope with house bill 498 that it would
bring bring relief to our community but
at the end of the 2021 session the
judicial branch attached a fiscal note
to that house bill which said that the
bill would be in excess of 636 thousand
dollars for 2022 and then got climbed to
over 850 000
for their fiscal note if we add mileage
to the bail commissioners presently then
that fiscal note
is a hurdle that we will never be able
to get over because we are a fiscally
conservative state
so prior to passage of this bill i would
ask if the legislative body to please
introduce support pass a bill that
ensures that our professional community
gets paid for the services that we
continue to provide
thank you all very much
representative testament
thank you thank you for taking my
question
we seem to be
nibbling around the edges
on what the real problem is
uh
what do you think of
a situation where we had 24-hour
seven days a week judges or magistrates
we you'd lose a job but we get the job
done
by people because you we're you're just
a stop gap to the
to the judge
i
i cannot speak on behalf of
the
judiciary um i believe the purpose of
the bail commissioner was to be able to
relieve the role of judges to not be
judges are
available for search warrants and other
scenarios i mean i have my judge's
personal
email i mean cell phone number in the
event that i have a situation that comes
up during my on call that i would need
to have him assist me with my decision
making but
to have judges on call you'd probably
have to expand
the number of judges that you have
appointed because 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year that's a lot
of judge time
and that's a big expense to the state of
new hampshire as well because then
you're going to have to absorb their
salary their retirement all of those
things
my opinion just an opinion
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman
so my understanding is if you if you
answer the phone a bail commissioner has
to go right
what would it look like
if the bill commissioners were to
thank you
what was the word i was looking for
if the if the if the bill commissioners
were to organize themselves over a
weekend or whatever it was and say you
know what we're not answering the phone
what what would the consequence of that
look like
the
pandemonium in the within the police
departments absolute pandemonium it
would not no i don't think that much
would happen
in the courts monday through friday
on during their work their business
hours but your police departments would
be overwhelmed the cells would be full i
can't imagine that they or they'd be
releasing people out to the community
that shouldn't be released
if they're trying to
not fill their cells so it would be it
would be chaos utter chaos
and we can't organize because as i
mentioned earlier
we can't get a list of who the bail
commissioners are in this here in the
state
it's a pretty tightly held secret
representative newman
thank you mr chair and
taking my question
so it i'm trying to understand
what your position is i mean currently
you don't get the forty dollars
and you would then have to calculate
what your mileage you expected your
mileage to be
as you went to the place double that
figure out which mileage is and now
instead of not getting your
forty dollars all we would do by passing
this bill would mean that you would not
get your hundred dollars or 55 yes sir
that's absolutely right thank you
and again i just want to point out it
would drive up any fiscal note for any
potential new
legislation representative marston
thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
questions
i sometimes ask the wrong questions so
hopefully this one will go through
if we you're not in favor of this bill
you're in an opposition
based on that testimony
if some of us were to decide to itl this
bill that would not offend you
i would not be offended and i apologize
to any other bail commissioners which
are there are very few right that would
be offended um because we would really
like the focus to be on as i've stated
and i agree with that and thank you for
your time you're welcome sir
seno
representative soon
thank you you commented this is a
question
the bail commissioner uh family
is a tightly held secret by whom there's
the administrative office of the courts
so within the court system yes ma'am
the police departments do have bail
commissioner names
i have requested bail commissioner
contact information in the past and have
been told that it's not something that i
can gain access to
listen the issue of whether that list is
public or not is not i'm sorry if you
need to bring something up
my personal experience i'll just put it
that way
seeing thank you seeing no hands raised
i want to
thank the witness for her for her
testimony thank you all very much
the committee now calls jim moody
good afternoon
mr chairman
chair people
um my name is jim moody i'm a bail
commissioner at hooksett new hampshire i
respond to
merrimack county and hillsborough county
i'm primarily
i'm on a
calendar
in manchester work anywhere from six to
12 days a month depending on vacancies
on the schedule
i'm a retired army national guard
colonel i've reser i've served the great
state of new hampshire in this nation
for 31 years
i became a bail commissioner primarily
as another form of public service
i honestly
you know the pay was not an issue having
said that
i didn't expect to work for free
currently
after three years my average is between
60 and 70 percent getting paid
um last year i
clocked in approximately 4 000 miles
um
i'm
testifying in opposition to this bill
for most of the reasons that we're
already stated
you know mileage is not the issue
getting paid our 40 fees is the issue
um the
representative over here asked about um
you know seeing multiple
defendants in manchester i have no idea
how many people i'm gonna see anytime i
get a call it starts with one and i end
up with five or six
um
how to uh charge you know each of these
defendants you know when i'm not when i
don't know who i'm gonna see
um i see actually is a penalty um
you know if i charge one you know the
entire amount and and no one else
you know i don't think that's fair um
but again you know as uh most the other
bail commissioners stated the 40 fee is
is the issue not mileage um and
representative abbas um i'm not an
accountant but i'm married to one
um
so for mileage and expenses um is you
know if you itemize your taxes uh it's a
deduction
um it will it will not equal um mileage
for instance that if we did get paid
through this bill it will be less but at
least it's something so we can claim you
know mileage office supplies you know
envelopes stamps you know things of that
nature
and thank you for your testimony my
concern was that if this were to become
law that you would not be able to
itemize that anymore in future tax
filings that is correct and i'm not sure
which one's more equitable that's why i
was when i was getting that but i think
i think the mileage in this bill would
actually pay us more however
again you know with with the pay rate
it may it may balance out i don't know
um you know because again if we're only
getting paid 60 to 70 of the time and
not collecting those mileage fees uh it
may be more beneficial to to claim it on
our taxes as an expense
would it be possible that you might
actually get paid less
potentially
yes sir
thank you
um
i have no further comments again most of
the
other bail commissioners already covered
what uh i wanted to cover so thank you
bending questions
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony
are there any members of the public
present who wish to testify that have
not testified already
seeing no hands raised we will now close
the public hearing on senate bill
361.
just to the members of the community
we're going to do several exec executive
sessions in a row now
some of these are early deadline bills
the deadline is thursday the the 14th
they were they were assigned on friday
actually representative speaker we spoke
that morning i gave you the list of
bills and then
by that afternoon that list changed i
hope you didn't call me a liar because
but but we
we let's get them all done okay
so at this time
at this time when i opened the executive
session on senate bill 456
instead establishing a law enforcement
conduct review committee
in the police standards and training
council on making an appropriation
therefore
at this time the chair recognizes
representative welch to make a motion
i move the senate bill 456 be referred
for interim study
is there a second the second by
representative boarding
and the reason i say that is because
there's an identical bill in the senate
it doesn't make sense to have the
finance committee convene another
session
to do what they've already done
and i just think it makes sense
why waste time
very well said
anyways anyone else wish to speak
representative ray newman
i just have a parliamentary inquiry what
so if we kill the senate bill then they
kill the bill over there
there's just something else in it that's
god
when you say the term kill i believe
your kill i mean if we in extreme
legislation
right inexpedient to legislate
is it possible that that would happen in
the senate and then you don't have this
or
is
that's my problem don't worry i don't i
don't want to say it's impossible i
i don't want to
i've been in some communication with
some members of the other body and
explained to him what
we intended on doing
thank you mr with this one so
it's the notice has been delivered
representative yes i'd like to add one
thing just to kind of clear this up
when we had the commission where we
uh
basically came up with this bill
i asked senator carson who was the only
other legislative member of that
committee
if she was going to do it and she said
no
i said well then i'll do it
i figure at this point
she didn't want to do it she doesn't
have
to fix it
thank you for that clarification
representative
mr chairman i i want to note that
the motion is
inter study which means that if the
senate were to kill the house of bill
we could probably reintroduce
this back to the house floor
and just for a point of clarification i
would not want to put this on the
consent count the reason why is that i
would likely move to table
this
bill
it's on the consent calendar it gets a
little so please don't
we don't need to have someone
necessarily again we just won't put it
on and then
if for some reason i'm not there someone
do that in my honor but we'll do that
and we can always if things go fall we
can then take it off the table and go
that route okay
representative ray newman
thank you i now have a much better
parliamentary understanding
this time we'll now move the question if
you in support of the
motion of interim study please say yay
if you are opposed uh please say nay the
clerk will not call the roll vice
chairman roy yes representative welch
yes representative burke yes
representative rhodes yes representative
greene yes
clerk votes yes representative testerman
yes representative folsom yes
representative pratt yeah yes
representative manaval yes
representative bradley yes
representative espitia
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
21 yays zero nays
[Music]
and for the record i object to this
going on consent
this time we will now close the uh
representative will you prepare a report
majority report i'll do that
thank you
at this time we will now close the
executive session on senate bill 456.
at this time we will now open the
executive session on senate bill
relative to creating a border board to
review police incidents involving
citizens affected by mental health
issues
burt do you wish to be recognized to
make a motion
yes
i'll make a motion uh
senate bill 376 of ought to pass
and then seconded by representative
harry catherine
represented bertie wish to speak to your
motion i would thank you
i believe
senate bill 376 is very needed
and the reason is
the new hampshire ag
senator guida said
is very narrow
guided on what he can do which is is it
justified
a police shooting or was it not
justified pretty much that's it
i personally uh
have seen two cases myself in new
hampshire where
i think other alternatives could have
happened even though the a.g in one of
the cases said that it was justified the
other case he said we don't know
um
that they're
reviewing those situations
could come to learn and learn from and
to teach the the law enforcement that
there are other alternatives if that's
the case after reviewing those
situations
so that's why i support this i think
it's very needed and i very much welcome
it and i hope you support it
representative espio
i think it's chair um i agree with her
with my colleague from goffstown i think
this is definitely something that's
needed
and you know i know that law enforcement
has a difficult job and just making sure
we can find ways to help them and
provide some accountability is important
i i roast my head because i also you
know i know that senator guida had
proposed an amendment on this bill um
he's that he passed out about
having a program administrator
um
that would help kind of guide the
you know help
help guide us along and make sure that
you know if they needed any help that
they would be a staff person to help
them through that
um do we want to consider this some this
proposed amendment i mean we'd have to
send to ols but
my understanding was the the amendment
but it's not an
amendment but the suggested language was
just adding and one under that
underlying section for facilitation
instruction of additional training
sessions yeah so if i
oh
so he said
so yes and then he gave us another one
that added a program administrator
so there's two of them yeah so there's
so yeah there's the one that holly
originally gave us and then there was
another one that the center gave us in
the afternoon
for your point of order please please
state your point of order
uh amendment has been talked about but i
don't see it nor does it have a number
has it been approved written by osaka
i have to rule on the point
you what you're saying is is correct uh
there is no
drafted amendment
before the committee at this time
uh i believe the representative from
nashua
well
that representative from nashua
was mentioning just
bringing to our attention i think the
chair was not in the was not present
when the senator was discussing this i
assumed he was just
bringing it up to me not trying to be
out of order so i i would
with that being said if
it's the will of the committee to not
pass it because
if we're not gonna if you want this um
what this language is to be an amendment
i would suppose
you oppose the author pass and we'll see
where we're at
um
creating a new position i i don't i
don't know what the new position is i
wouldn't know where to begin with that
i've never heard
an amendment boy
unless you had it
it would have to be prepared i think
what what the
the understanding was if we would want
to consent to consider that we would
need
to to do that if we vote ought to pass
uh i i will also say this we are on a
extremely tight deadline
if for some reason
someone were to prepare if we were to
pass this and there were to be
an amendment drafted we always can move
for reconsideration provide the bill is
still in the committee
all right
an amendment
i would say that again but turn your
microphone on
uh mr chairman
representative thank you uh if i
understood right
the bill as is will work
it's just something that they wanted to
add if i
understood right but maybe not
but you know bottom line the committee
can uh the senate or the other body can
request a committee of conference and
fix it there
is a chance at this late stage
i would say pass it
representative marston yeah
an inquiry of the chair could we not
have a floor amendment on this
there's no rule saying you can't do one
thank you that's all i wanted to know
there are some procedural restrictions
on when you have to have that done by
representative harry gathered um the
bill also says this act shall take
effect upon this passage
but on the amendment it says um june
30th 2023.
so was
so if the committee really wants to have
to consider a mimic can we withdraw the
motion to ought to pass and have it
brought up
on the next wednesday for the next
session
i will tell you this my recommendations
is just i'm one person which
quite often is not followed
is if we were to vote on the ought to
pass even if we were unanimous on
if provided the bill is still in the
committee which means
i don't
we haven't turned it
we haven't turned it into the clerk of
the house once it's delivered to the
clerk it's out of the committee
we could consider
reconsideration
on wednesday our deadline
is thursday the 14th
so
i'm inclined to suggest
we
pass the bill if someone really feels
strongly about
the the
a proposed amendment down the line and
they were to have it together and i
get over overwhelmed by the large number
of members of the committee i would
consider
reopening the executive session to
reconsider it to then we can go from
that route or the senator could go to
ols and get it himself
or if or perhaps as the our friend from
portsmouth recommended that it can be
done by a member of the other body as
well
there is a problem with the
other body drafting a amendment since
it's already passed the senate as
written and it comes to us as
and we pass it as a they amended it
there is no need for anything
that the senate can do because there is
it's because we've already concurred
with them
i i don't know if that's entirely
accurate
but
the they can
the house
can approve an amendment separate from
what the other body has done
right all right
it
a senator excuse me for saying that
can file
or sponsor an amendment
for a senate bill that's in the house
they can still do that provided a member
of this committee were to introduce it
so it would have to be introduced by
someone on the committee that's not a
substitute
so
our clarification
inquiry
is it for certain that if we uh
pass this bill today
that we can reconsider the bill at
another
we would have to reconsider it but the
only day that we are scheduled to meet
before the deadline is wednesday i
although it's unlikely for us to have a
snowstorm
we
we had a lot of subcommittee hearings
snowed out and i'm just saying if for
some reason
something whatever's going on that we
can't make it on wednesday we don't meet
the deadline so i would prefer to move
it along at least we have a
opportunity
and then then
but
is it guaranteed
i suppose i don't i have the as the
chair have the discretion whether to
open the executive session or not but
thank you thank you thank you
we can they can clean this up in a uh
in a committee of conference or not
pass it now
all right represent representative
welcome
yes this uh
amendment it creates a position
for the training
why would we
do that if they're only going to train
enough to for every police department in
the state once it's done it's done then
you have an employee getting paid it
just doesn't make sense i say we just
pass it
thank you i would remind everyone that
next week even though the calendar says
thursday the actual deadline is the
paperwork including the committee report
has to be to the committee assistant by
noon on wednesday
i'm really glad you said that
all right
i'm really i'm really thankful that
representative jack decided to
substitute today thank you
i was just going to ask a freshman
question
does this go to a second committee is
that why it's an early bill
my understanding it does
can't they put the amendment on
let them do it
amen
and mr chairman the weather is going to
be 64 degrees partially sunny
next wednesday
this time we will now move the question
if you're in support of the motion of
ought to pass
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch
yes representative burt yes
representative rhodes
representative greene baby
yes
clark votes yes representative testament
representative folsom yes representative
pratt yes representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative pantalakis yeah
representative jack yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse yes representative
ray newman yes and i'm glad that the
freshman representative is here
representative sue newman
yes representative manaval yes
representative bradley yes
representative especially
yes
chair votes yes chairman abbas
21 years zero nays
anyone wish to move for consent
so i moved
and represented bert you'll prepare a
majority report
thank you
this time we will now close the
executive session on senate bill
376.
at this time we now open the executive
session on senate bill 361 requiring the
bail commissions to be reimbursed for
mileage travel and the performance of
their duties
does anyone does anyone wish to be
recognized to make a motion
representative board now you're
recognized
chairman i uh
i'll make a motion to ought to pass
i'm ready to speak to him
uh there's another member we should be
recognized to make him sec second it has
to be
member a substitute cannot make a motion
representative espio
you know actually no never mind
representative roy you're recognizing
making a motion of being speeding to
legislate yes i'm moving expedient to
legislate on sb 361. i'll second that
representative roy you're recognized
just speak on your motion thank you um
in light of the testimony we heard um
from
that people who actually do the work
they don't want this bill um and
far be it for us to force them to accept
money that they're never gonna get
anyway so
representative espitia
so
i agree with like you know i think
i think they definitely don't want it
and i get it um i think i want i was
actually thinking about moving in um
interim study i think i think that there
is work that needs to be done on
studying ways that we can actually pay
our bill commissioners um because it is
i mean it sounds like a rough gig um and
and
um and they provide a service that's
important to our state and the fact that
they're not being properly compensated
is is pretty it's pretty bad but um no
i'll be supporting the itl motion and uh
yeah
representative representative pandolakis
yes i just had a question of uh we
passed a bill in this committee i
thought that said
that the state would reimburse them did
that get killed along the way
i believe you're referring to hp 498. uh
representative mitch i believe you were
a
sponsor a co-sponsor that bill what was
do you mind just telling the me what the
fate of that was
i believe that i
i would have to i would actually have to
look it up to be honest with you i know
it it passed in this committee with a
positive recommendation passed it passed
on the house floor as well what i'm not
sure of is what happened in the senate
uh and what happened with funding which
was
it it may not have made it out it was a
may not have made out of the house
finance committee either way it's it
i was fine it did not make it out of the
house finance committee so that that was
the
downfall of that policy thank you very
much
representative boarding
thank you mr chairman
uh one of the reasons i
oppose the itl motion
is because
um
i realize that the bill commissioners
are being
stiffed
for both their fees
and their
uh
outage
but i'm hoping that one day
that
uh they will become uh
actually employed by the the court
and be paid for their services
and at that time we will have be on the
record that the outage that they would
be
uh
paid for
are is already on record that they
should be paid for
so
having a policy in
rsas say
that they are entitled to mileage
if they are then paid by the court would
not only get their fee
but also their knowledge
thank you
and
if there was ever any type of magistrate
system
if there was ever a magistrate system i
would hope that
that policy would give or provide some
type of special consideration for the
bail commissioners who've worked very
hard doing a public service for a long
time and have you said
been
been stiffed as we say on being paid so
that's just my take on it representative
pandelagas
i just couldn't vote for it because i
don't think it's fair if you have nine
clients
got the merrimack jail
and only one of them is going to be
judged the mileage that's not fair
representative harry garth
i don't know i think i'm feeling a
little differently about this because i
looked at the hearing notes from the
senate
and it says summary of testimony
presented in opposition none
so i'm just curious
and it lists some of the same folks that
testified
and i'm just
i think if if the senator was here might
have went differently
i i will tell you that
assuming that information is accurate i
can say they clearly change their mind
no
but they're all shaking their head no
but even if even if they were yes
they've changed their mind clearly based
on the testimony given to this committee
that's true
but i i from what i understand they even
disagree that he changed their mind
they're saying that they were opposed to
the whole time
blame it on the clerk
senate clerk yes what what's the issue
i i believe the committee report was
referring to remote testimony
uh submitted against i'm not sure it may
just be an error in the committee report
but there were these people were at the
senate hearing and did oppose the bill
at the time
and thank you for the clarification
representative
just the the status the status of the
bill um from the last session sb 722 was
actually laid on the table in the senate
uh i believe it was one of the bills
that didn't make it because of covet
thank you
this time we can now move the question
if you were in support of the motion of
inx being to legislate please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes representative
burt yes representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes clark votes
yes
representative testament yes
representative folsom yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative panolakis
representative jack yes representative
boardney
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative sue newman yes
representative manaval no
representative bradley yes
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
19 yays
two nays
move for representative roy moves for
consent
okay
represent
representative be preparing a minority
report
representative roy will prepare the
majority report
this time we will now close the
executive session on senate bill
361.
i was just closing the executive
executive session on senate bill 361.
which one
this time we'll now open the executive
session on senate bill 401
making appropriations to the department
of transportation for local highway aid
into the body worn and dashboard camera
fund and permitting departments of
transportation to operate dash cameras
in fleet vehicles
make a statement before you
ask for a motion
yes make a statement i know that the
municipal association has
asked for an amendment to this bill
and um
to make it possible to uh pass this uh
correctly
uh i think we need to consider her
amendment
and
to clarify what would that amendment
look like
i don't know
representative expedia
i was not going to go into the weeds on
this one but um it was they said that
town isn't like
is it it has to be political subdivision
instead of town that's what they said
because it
it's
but
um
but that was on the
um amen
it's not proposed there's a drafted
amendment actually drafted
correctly
that's amendment number 2022-1
339s which
i wouldn't support the amendment myself
but what i'm saying is with this
amendment yeah
uh
they're talking about the language and
the amendment uh the motion is ought to
pass on the under just so and also they
did say though the reason they need the
amendment is so that they can be able to
give the money straight to
municipalities
because otherwise as drafted right now
apparently they don't have the mechanism
to do that but you can give that to the
finance people too
so my interest my understanding is right
right now if this
the money can't be used to offset
local funds that have already been
budgeted or appropriate
so
if that's the case
any
these funds for the year of 2022
suppose unless the town didn't pass a
budget
they would have already appropriated at
least they're in the process of doing
that
so
for 20 it would have to be for something
in 2023 or in the future
which the underlying bill would do so i
was not clear that the amendment was
that's just my interpretation that that
amendment would not have
if i'm
and that's just my
i always like to say i sound correct it
doesn't mean i am i i understood that it
needed to change because you could not
use it on
the word town it had to be political
that is in the proposed amendment the
proposed amendment contains that flaw if
it were to be entertained by the
committee would need to have some
grammatical changes representative
and my understanding of what the
municipal association person was saying
was that
the funds couldn't supplement
monies that were otherwise to be used
but that
in the case of monies that could be
available in 2022
the town couldn't accept them if they
hadn't passed
a certain rsa applicable to their town
without this
enabling aspect
um
and that was what she was trying to
correct with the addition
uh
not the town one but the other one
my own point is if the town hasn't
improved the use of the money because
that money is only going to apply to a
partial
part of the project here
if the town hasn't approved it yet that
money could be held up waiting for that
town to approve it and it may not even
get approved meanwhile other communities
may
have may
already approved it and they would be
they might not be eligible
i mean every town has the opportunity to
put these applications in whether it's
through warrendark whatever their their
local government system is so they're
all entitled to do that
so i don't if they haven't done that
already
but that money could be held up i mean
that in a bad way but let's say they
hold it up in the town for whatever
reason doesn't pass the warrant article
so
representative another freshman question
um since this is going to a second
committee can a
representative from this committee who
likes the amendment and wants to fix it
can they get it
fixed and run through ols and present it
at the next committee
and have it done right
this is a second committee bill
that's
what they do in that committee that's
i'm just explaining i'm not sure the
amendment is
i'm not sure it's necessary for what
this is trying to accomplish
so
another 29 applications
made for the camera grants 29 were
granted
at this point in time correct
the reason i brought it up is i don't
think the municipal association would
have brought it up to us if they didn't
think it was important if they were just
like oh it's not a big deal like i think
i think they meant to but like i said
can we handle another committee so it's
funny
well
i think it's it's in fairness someone
mentioned an amendment i don't the
witness i haven't looked at that we gave
her the witness an opportunity to look
at it and they said well if you were to
consider that this is some grammatical
issues
there was more guidance on which was
appreciated but i don't
i'm not sure we're going to consider
that amendment
representative walls thank you mr
chairman the
catherine from the municipal association
and i quote strongly supports and
suggests an amendment so
just take it you know as it is she
strongly supports it but would suggest
an amendment so
okay mr chairman
representative i might point out that
this will probably go to finance and the
chairman of the finance committee is
also a sponsor
so if that amendment is necessary i'm
sure they'll take care of it
i'll leave that to the great folks on
the finance committee
representative roy you wish to be
recognized to make a motion about the
past
iu uh i move out to pass sb41
that's been seconded by representative
rhodes
representative roy wish to speak to your
motion
not so much
but i will it um
we heard the testimony all of us heard
it um
this this money would be appreciated by
the the towns the the bridges that are
um
in pretty rough shape um i think this
will be seen as a as a as a win for all
of our our communities our constituents
and um i'm pleased to be able to be part
of it and get them some money that they
need
i don't i don't know the status of the
bridges in every district
i know in rockingham county district 8
salem new hampshire
we we have a bridge that is has some
structural integrity issues as listed
uh for any members who have a bridge in
their district that has an issue
i i can't imagine you vote against this
one so i'm going to be supporting this
representative jack
thank you i i couldn't get the testimony
from the people but this is enough money
to do about 60 bridges
representative espitia 60 bridges that
we can help fix here in new hampshire
and
you know i'm excited because i think
this will provide good funding
especially for communities that
may may not be able to bond for or
might need the money to cover all their
stuff
representative burke
thank you mr chairman um i hope the
senate also fixes my problem because i
will be voted no on this
is the uh privacy
issues
uh with d.o.t i support d.o.t having
dash cams in rear cams i have them in my
vehicle
i think it's smart for everybody to have
a dash cam
where i have a problem is when the
gentleman said
when i asked him what is going to happen
you know within that three days before
it's deleted
can somebody else another department or
anybody really
come in and grab that footage and he
said yes
i know the dot
easy pass is deleted fairly quickly i
think almost immediately once uh you
know a member here said that
the plate is
verified and then it's deleted
that is what i want to support as if
that dash cam there was no accidents
that day there was no murders in front
of that vehicle uh there was no
robberies in front of that vehicle um
you know there was no crimes around that
vehicle then in my eyes for privacy
it should be
removed immediately
because
i do not want the government to have one
more avenue
of
seeing who's doing what driving down
what road
we have been very clear in new hampshire
against that we passed constitutional
amendments to make sure that our privacy
is upheld in new hampshire
and here we are going to
support a bill that can allow somebody
to go in and grab that footage before
the d.o.t
deletes it on the third day
and he even said yeah we can keep it if
we
think we should use it for training
purposes
um you know this is not what this is
supposed to be for is to protect the
workers
you know in crashes uh it protects
you know our our
cost of the vehicles um you know to make
sure that we know who is did the
accident you know whose fault um
you know i support cameras
um it's just this one piece and i do
support
the bridges um
you know that need to be fixed so i hope
the senate fixes this problem so at the
end i can vote for it in the house but
today i'm to vote now
representative bert
yes
uh
on
on lines
22 to 24 it says the stored recording
may only be used by the requesting party
for a lawful purpose including as
evidence
in a judicial or administrative
proceeding
so
i'm asking
if someone were just to walk into the
room
from
whatever part of the government without
any explanation why they want to make
a copy of the recording
do you believe that that would be
permitted under the paragraph i mean i
read that as they have to have a lawful
purpose for asking for it to be stored
longer than three days
what line is that lines 22-24
the way i'm reading it is that another
government agency can request
the footage
and at that point then it's free as far
as i'm concerned for that agency you
know i i'd be nervous on why they need
it and what it's for
again new hampshire we've passed
constitutional amendments that's huge
to protect our privacy against
government
and we have to maintain that in new
hampshire
and so the way i'm reading it is you
know they have to delete it in three
days
but if i understood the gentleman from
d.o.t he said that they can keep the you
know which is right here it says it here
that they can keep it if they seem
you know that they want to keep it
um and i'm reading administrative
proceedings
or
judiciary
you know that
other departments police
could come and grab this
and and you know that's not what new
hampshire stands for
well
my question to you is wouldn't them
grabbing it need to be for a lawful
purpose
and
if they cannot demonstrate a lawful
purpose
then i would i would agree with you that
that would not be permitted under the
law
uh correct but i'm also you know
you know unlawful
you know where is that in the the rsas
what is lawful they could go in and say
you know we just want this one footage
because we believe
uh
representative welch drove down this
road and he said he didn't
so we want to grab that
and that's not the
in my eyes that's not the intent of this
bill
it's not to spy on us it is to help the
public roads the bridges that we need to
fix
and to protect
you know these accidents that do happen
um
you know to protect the scene and to
protect you know what happened you know
we're going to find out what's going to
happen because of that footage and i
support all that it's
that three-day hold
in if somebody grabs that which this
says they can
um what will they do with that through
you know that video
question
representative testament
the constitution clearly says
we have a right to privacy
and it doesn't say for lawful purposes
for unlawful purposes you say we have a
right to privacy
uh
i'm not even sure i like them having
video cameras
you know i think there's a violation of
our privacy we keep saying well it's not
much but you know
you know
the three days clearly is too much
you know i think if if they drive if
they can drive the truck home
you know they don't need the video
so just to clarify when we speak of
expectations of privacy
when these cameras
these vehicles are
in public
it's on you when you're in public you're
on a public road when representative
welts is driving
on whatever road
route 93 whatever road it's a public
road so to say you have an expectation
of privacy when you're on a public road
is inconsistent with the term privacy
the expectation of privacy would be if
they're filming inside your house
that type of situation on private
property if anyone shows up with a
camera on your pr you tell them to turn
that off if that makes you comfortable
because it's your property i'm saying
we're talking about when someone's in
public
all right and these accidents that we're
hearing about is public property so
i understand and i respect people's
right to privacy
this is not this is not violating that
because it's
has to do
with when they're on public property so
i i'm just confused by
i understand that the concern about this
video being misused
just understand you are in
in a public place and if someone's
recording you
government or a private person
how can you say you have an expectation
of privacy can i answer that
i'll let representative rhodes speak to
him represent burger you can
respond thank you mr chairman i i would
like to point out that
a tesla vehicle has
cameras on the on their doors
so when you're driving on the road and
you pass a tesla you've been recorded
whether you guys realize that or not you
have been
and i think also
this might come out really wrong
god knows i'm famous for that
sometimes you have to give up the right
to be right i i think that
people are looking for this to say
something that it does not say
and are looking at for it to try to
accomplish something that it's
doesn't say that it's going to
accomplish
thank you mr chairman
the constitution says it could be the
right for privacy individuals right to
live free from governmental intrusion
and private or personal information is
natural essentially inherent i don't see
where they have a right to video
that license plate on your vehicle that
they can see no no well that's what i
was going to say was
the tesla
right john burt driving down the road
getting your license plate that's all
private
it says the supreme court has ruled that
the government cannot spy on us
in
you know and
you know i don't go you know
you know so when i say that you know i i
like the dash cam
and it's only going to be used for that
specific reason is for crash or
or a crime around it um you know i guess
i'd even you know have to look at that
but the supreme court has been very
clear
i can stand on the side of the road and
videotape anybody i want in pro in
public
the government can't we don't have
um
red light
cameras for a reason
because we've all both sides have always
voted those down because we don't want
to be spied on by the government we
passed a constitutional amendment which
is huge
because we don't want to be spied on
and for somebody to go in a you know
department a government department to
grab this video
i can't do it
if i
so how would you let me just ask this
how exactly
how much time do you want them to have
to be able to hold the video because if
you're not restoring if you record
something and you don't store it all it
is is just a live feed
so it has to be recorded and stored for
some period of time in order to make the
determination whether that
that recording
is
you know there's a crash or if there's
whatever those examples there needs to
be a certain period of time that they
need to figure okay we gotta now
maintain this footage
i'm saying if three days is too long if
we change that to two days would that
change anyone's mind here i'm just at
some point
it i'm not really sure what we're
talking about it's not an invasion of
privacy if it's stored for three days
or sorry if it's stored for one day or
two days but it is if it's stored for
three days because we're worried about
someone somehow accessing a computer
system
and keep in mind someone who works
doesn't have to assist them in doing
that because
they're going to have to work for the
department to give them the video
and they're not going to provide any
explanation why
they need the video that he's going to
give it away
and for what's what's happening here a
car driving by
you know what we're all feel good is if
it excludes any
recording being used uh being released
you know if it says that it cannot be
released
because the only purpose for this is
accidents
around this vehicle
because that's the intent that's what
the gentleman said you know we want this
camera
in case our car get our state car gets
hit
you know and he says that's the only
reason we want it or for training
purposes which i disagree with that one
but you know so if you wanted to make an
amendment saying that there's no release
of this video and after three days
the videos cleared i would support it
because i support everything else in
this bill it's the privacy part because
we've worked too hard to get where new
hampshire is to protect the privacy
and that's from both sides both sides
have worked hard for this
and
[Music]
mr chairman our our cars
classed as government cars
with the plates
yes and normally they're distinctly
marked even if they're not
i mean
my question would be to representative
burke
did you say you had a cam
in your car
do you have our plates on it
wouldn't you say that you were invading
my privacy
but i'm just saying you are saying this
about a
vehicle that would be taking pictures of
a car accident
that could go back to the person
that
might not have the evidence that they
need
and they're a government vehicle but so
are ours but why wouldn't that be all
right
i support that part i support if if the
state truck caught an accident or was in
an accident you know he's picking up
trash on the side of the road and in
some tractor trailer or a car or a
camper somebody cleans him out the car
i want that footage so i support that
part it is the possibility of the police
going in or someone else going in
another government agency which is
against the constitution and grabbing
that video the supreme court's been very
clear on it
they can't do it or they shouldn't do it
representative burke but when would the
you hit the record button there's just
been an accident someone needs to be
start the recording no record 20 record
24 hours
the video is not allowed to leave
if there's an accident then the video is
to be used at the end of the day or the
end of three days if there's no
accidents in those three days nobody can
grab that video just like the um tolls
nobody can grab those plates
in the tolls
i can't go to easy pass and say you know
i want to see every car that goes
through because i want to know if
representative welch went through the
toll today
i i can't do it
i just i just think that uh there was no
video cameras when the constitution was
written yes so we have to start some
presidents someplace well but the
constitution is very clear on privacy
it says government shall not
uh surveil the government or the public
in in back when the constitution was
written that means there won't be a
policeman on every corner with
binoculars going okay who's coming down
and make a log of it would you believe
mr burke
representative burke there was no police
officers at that time that's true yes
back in the good days
when we didn't need them all right let
let's let some representative marston is
not
joining this healthy conversation
thank you mr chairman
if i understand my fellow representative
bert saying that it's illegal and it's
based on a supreme court ruling
then if somebody went in and grabbed it
it would not be admissible in court and
would get thrown out based on the
supreme court's ruling so it becomes a
moot question
representative morrison that as well put
it in a legal government recording
uh would be
it would be suppressed
thank you
that was very well put representative
representative
welch
i just wanted to point out to everybody
and it happened during the testimony
here
that they are putting cameras up on the
poles on the highways and i've counted
at least a dozen of them in my travels
it's camera
surveilling the public
and can you clear it
at this time we will now
we'll now move the question
oh
represent walls i apologize thank you mr
chairman actually there are the majority
of all motor vehicles manufactured after
2016 have at least
two or three sometimes 10 cameras in
them including suvs tahoes pickup trucks
uh even bmw motorcycles all have the
cameras so
presume you're being recorded you are
this is 1984 on steroids
this time
representative pratt you recognized
i just had one concern and i'm pretty
sure it's gonna get caught in the
finance committee but um
they're talking about a million dollars
for
body cams police officers and 30 million
dollars for dwr department of
transportation vehicles
i think the priority is backwards there
by quite a bit but i think that'll be
caught in finance so i'm still going to
vote yes for it
even though i could say
at this time we will now move the
question if you can support the motion
of
support the motion of octopass as
amended
please say yes if you were opposed
please say no the clerk will now call
the roll
we're in the voting mode
no amendment oh did i did i say
amendment
rtp
if you can support the motion of ought
to pass please say yes if you're opposed
uh please say nay
the clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch yes representative burritt
no
representative rhodes yes
representative green
i'll vote anyway as long as i can get
out of here
i'll vote yes
clerk votes yes representative testerman
no representative folsom yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative panalakis yes
representative jack yes representative
bordenay yes
representative muse yes representative
ray newman
yes representative sue newman yes
representative manaval yes
representative bradley yes
representative espitia yes
and chairman abbas
chair votes yes
19 yays two nays
move for consent no i'm gonna fight this
one
you know a lot of people said i've been
too quiet the past couple house sessions
representative burr you'll be preparing
a minority report yes i will
representative roy the majority report
this time we'll now close the
executive session on senate bill 401.
representative harry katherine
i did we're not going to accept anything
else today but
i know you want to be recognized for
just a short personal privilege
all right so um on march i think it was
the seventh when i got that call that
renny had passed um from
representative cody
um i made a statement
and i just want to read that to you guys
um
i thought while i don't know where to
begin to express the pain of ronnie's
death while this is a devastating loss
to his beautiful wife and beautiful
girls who most of us met during um
the abolishment the death penalty death
penalty bill
and his extended family
we agree with each of you
and new hampshire and the usa
for rene has reached out far beyond new
hampshire i knew of rene however did not
personally meet him until my first term
as state rep
from hills 36 nashua in 2012.
i request and was assigned to criminal
justice and public safety committee at
the time the dean was chair
representative laura panchalakas and
representative randy christian served as
her vice chair both democrats
on the committee in new hampshire
amazingly they truly gelled and
supported the entire team during my
second term renny was chair and vice
chair was beth rod
and i served as the clerk
he asked me to sign on as co-sponsor of
hb 455 the abolishment of the death
penalty in new hampshire we all knew he
advocated for the right issues and
justice for all people realizing the
stacks were against um bipop
black indigenous people of color as well
as low-income persons
my third term he called he asked me to
be the ranking member well he convinced
me why i should accept the position of
ranking member
and take on extra responsibility
and i kind of smiled about that i say
that because he was always being an
encourager to stand up and fight for the
right things and every voice has has
that opportunity i've always been an
activist in nashua and manchester he
encouraged each committee member to
continue the advocacy for the people
throughout the state
i know i can speak for criminal justice
public safety committee not just
democrats his love of people and
determination truly rubbed off on many
of us over the years and other
committees because we never hesitated to
choose him as our number one in command
for new hampshire house of
representative
i will miss his check-in calls giving me
the choice to allow members to serve
after much friction respecting my
decision as a colleague
we all miss the love he had for the
people much prayer for all the family we
are forever indebted to the family be
blessed that he is at peace and have
left an amazing and beautiful history of
life that we all are proud of so our
fully submitted
representative gap
that was well said representative
harrygath right
at this time the
criminal justice and public safety
committee will be
adjourned
with a pretty long period of time
you